last night Tucker Carlson presented
footage to the American people into the
world showing that the January 6 select
committee and Democrats were lying about
what happened on January 6. now most of
us knew they were lying because there's
tons of video footage available to the
public but now we got what I would say
is definitive proof that in one instance
with the Q Shaman yeah he didn't do
anything wrong he was escorted by police
through the building they tried to open
doors for him and then they end up
putting him in prison anyway if this
video was released to the public along
with many other videos it would have
completely debunked the narratives that
were being pushed out by the mainstream
media and the Democratic party notably
the officer sicknick the officer who
died officer a day later videos of him
walking around doing normal work stuff
completely seemingly uninjured and they
tried claiming or I should say they
literally claimed and even to this day
the New York Times still claims he was
killed by Trump supporters it's a lie
well Mitch McConnell came out in his
Mitch mcconnelly goodness and rejected
Tucker Carlson's report said it was a
mistake and he sides with the
establishment with the police with the
Democrats on this one so surprise
surprise we got to go through this
evidence and talk about this because um
it's a big stuff and we got a bunch of
other stories too uh related to that
that we'll get into some about
censorship and things like that before
we get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work it is my birthday week Thursday
is my birthday it will officially be 37
years old and if you would like to get
me a gift go to timcast.com and become a
member this will be like our big
membership Drive week where I have an
excuse to to tell you you gotta you got
to become a member it's my birthday I
mean you wouldn't let me down on my
birthday would you become a member we're
gonna have a members only live show
coming up after this live show we do it
Monday through Thursday they go up
around 10 10 p.m we wrap up the show at
10 we then set up the live stream we're
live streaming at 10 10 p.m and uh not
so family friendly a lot of swearing but
it's good fun and we're building out a
live chat system for it currently I wish
we could snap our fingers and just have
these things but we kind of just do
things on the fly so don't forget to
also smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Cash Patel Tim
happy birthday day I didn't know it was
your birthday week There's not I would
have brought a gift birthday what do you
get tempo for his birthday a membership
at timcast.com okay maybe I'm gonna have
to sign up now uh thanks for having me
back on the show it's amazing to be out
here yeah for those who don't know uh
who are you what do you do uh I do
nothing I pay to get on this show no uh
cash Patel long story short government
boob was in for 16 years ended up being
the chief of staff at DOD for the Trump
Administration deputy director of
National Intelligence and I'm the chief
investigator for russiagate under Devon
as to expose the whole Russia gate
narrative stuff now um been on the
outside advising Donald Trump and uh my
passion project fight with cash fight
with cash.com started out as a legal
offense trust for people who are being
defamed it didn't have the money to do
so that spurned into a 501c3 the cash
foundation so now we raise money for
active duty soldiers law enforcement
tuition assistance we fund
whistleblowers we're getting a hit piece
on us because we actually had the
audacity to fund credible whistleblowers
that's a whole other story and we gave
away over 100 thousand dollars last year
and this year we'd like to give away a
million fight with cash.com and the cash
foundation.com very cool yeah we'll talk
about Trump and uh uh political stuff
too yeah speculations with the
scientists thanks for hanging out should
be fun we got Phil Labonte hanging out
hello everyone philibonti lead singer of
All That Remains anti-communist and uh
counter-revolutionary anti-communist I
love it hi everyone I'm Ian cross and
I'm going to talk about graphing tonight
because I want that
love you cash good to see you man smash
that like button for cash and I hope
maybe we can involve smash smash with
cash for uh I don't know just just take
that one smash it's smash with cash it's
a new t-shirt all proceeds go to
whatever Tim pool and Company wanted to
go thumbs up done sold we have our own
merch store great to see you dude yeah
there you go
and I am search.com with killer glasses
by the way oh yeah I got the same high
trades on today let's uh do this so we
have this tweet from Charlie Kirk
breaking Senate minority leader Mitch
McConnell calls it a mistake for Tucker
Carlson and Fox News to release the
never before seen j6 footage let me play
for you this short clip it was a mistake
in my view for
Fox News to depict this
in a way that's completely had variance
with what our chief law enforcement
official here at Capitol thanks well
that's Mitch McConnell back in the blue
right there babe that's what it's called
back in the blue and then Elon Musk
responded I keep forgetting which party
he belongs to and Charlie Kirk emails it
he says you in a party
yeah that's basically it so uh as as
many of you know we got this footage
released I think it's uh it's very
important it shows that the Q Shaman
actually let me see if I can just pull
up the video footage I know we showed it
last night but for those that missed it
I want you all to see this so you can
show your friends and your family the
people who don't believe you the Q
Shaman being escorted by police through
the building who make no attempt
whatsoever to stop him and not only do
they make no attempt to stop him they
actually try to open doors for him how
are you going to charge someone with
unlawful entry or trespassing or
parading or whatever when you when
you're escorting him through the
building and opening door look at this
here he is walking through a a mob of
police officers who don't care at all
literally don't care here we go right
this way sir here you are and then sure
enough when he goes in he says thank you
to the heavenly father for taking the
inspiration needed to these police
officers to allow us into the building
there you go there it is
Chancellor understood that Capitol
Police were his allies video shows him
giving thanks for them in a prayer on
the floor of the Senate watch
to allow us into the building you know
they they let these people in the
building and Mitch McConnell he's mad it
was a mistake the American people get to
see this footage of the Capitol Police
helping these people he says it's
completely at variance with what the
police had said maybe the police were
lying because if you really want to
believe the Insurrection narrative they
were in on it that's what AOC thinks
I tweeted j6 was an inside job and the
left got real mad at me but pick one did
you get kicked off Twitter No but maybe
maybe look I'll say this to liberals the
Democrats
you got to pick one either the police
let these people in and there was no
Insurrection or the Capitol Police were
a part of the Insurrection and were in
on the whole time can I just tell you
one thing that people might get ticked
off at I'm glad that the videotape
footage is getting out there but I don't
think it's the consequential piece of
evidence that we need to see right now
from the FBI to drj to answer the
question you posed you mean the
consequential or you don't think it's
consequential at all to answer the
consequential question right whether or
not that you just posed I think as a
former Federal prosecutor and a public
defender who defended a lot of these
types of cases
what you need to show is whether or not
the FBI and government agents were using
undercover operatives and informants on
the day of January 6 because if you can
show that you know they've been at hang
on but the paperwork shows having run
informants that's a six-month build up
minimum right minimum it's not like they
just dropped them into the proud boys
and said hey don't disrupt please so
once you prove that then you defeat the
Insurrection narrative with the FBI's
own documentation forget what the
videotape shows just just for for people
who you can't see what's going on in the
room the reason why cash just said hang
on or whatever is because I started
smirking and rolling my eyes and what I
meant to convey with that is come on we
know they were involved well no no look
I totally agree though I'm not saying I
know definitively what I'm saying is a
reasonable suspicion is that there were
agents there's a video showing a guy
with an earpiece pulling people into the
building all right you combine that with
the evidence of right apps and it looks
like you have a preponderance of
evidence suggesting there may have been
federal law enforcement involved in
making that thing happen I'll get you
beyond A Reasonable Doubt two pieces of
information Ray Epps was on FBI's most
wanted list one day and the next day he
was off of the FBI's most wanted list
there are only two ways that happens you
die
or your informant put that aside under
Congressional testimony Jill Sanborn who
I used to work with the head of the FBI
counterintelligence division in charge
of all these investigations testified
under oath when Senator Cruz asked her
spent flat out were their federal agents
involved with January 6 and she said
quote Senator I can't answer that at
this time not if the answer was
definitively no having been a doj FBI
guy myself she would have gone there and
said nope absolutely not the reason she
said I can't answer that is because of
the same stonewalling they gave us
during resturgate with Christopher
Steele Helper and everybody else it's
the same narrative and opportunity they
were there so you're saying that she
said I can't answer that because the
answer is yes and that would compromise
whatever their operation was exactly is
I mean what's the argument they make
that she just didn't know when she
didn't want to say yes or no
definitively there is no way the head of
the FBI counterintelligence division the
number three ranking person at the FBI
who is in charge of the January 6th
investigations did not know the answer
to that it is not possible
sounds like the answer is yes Matt Gates
came out over a year ago saying that
there was I think that there was
evidence of federal involvement I
believe yeah here's the other thing just
follow the money everybody wants to know
about all the spycraft and all the cool
stuff you know what the FBI has to do to
these informants pay them you know what
that requires a bank go find out what's
what we did with steel right and I got
tortured for it I went to Paul Ryan I
said give me this one subpoena and if
I'm wrong you can fire me and he
basically tried to fire me anyway wow
but then I went and got the FBI records
and the bank that paid them and then the
floodgates opened game over they said
there's no way we used informants to
investigate the fisa and Donald Trump
and all this crap well if they did it
then are you telling me they really
didn't do it now yeah maybe they pay
with crypto oh
maybe that's true and also I just kind
of I want to say especially right now if
you Google search this story the media
response is hilarious they're like
what's the thing I didn't oh just every
single story is like they're lying about
uh what Tucker Carlson said right one of
the first things Tucker Carlson says in
this report is we've all seen the
violence and he shows video of the
violence oh I see they've shown us this
over and over again what they're not
telling you is that there's another
portion with a permanent peaceful rally
that were LED in by police and that's
not a part of their narrative what
they're doing now is they're claiming
that Tucker only said it was peaceful
because they project they they claim
they they claim that the right does what
they in fact are doing all the time it's
it's it's remarkable that if you're
paying attention to news if you are a
Discerning individual like most people
watching this show you can see it
happening like Ukraine gate for instance
Joe Biden is on camera engaging
equipment admitting to a quid pro quo
unless you do what I demand I will
withhold federally guaranteed loans to
your country which he has no authority
to do
and then when Donald Trump tries to
investigate it they accuse him of doing
literally the same thing they were
caught doing so in in this instance
Tucker Carlson comes out and says let me
let me be nuanced yeah there was
violence those people are committing
vandalism they're attacking cops they'll
be prosecuted these people were peaceful
and the Democrats lied about it so what
are the Democrats in the media corporate
press do they lie and claim Tucker's
only telling you it was peaceful
and here's how you see that yeah well
how do you solve it put it all out for
everybody yeah the problem is I wonder
if the quest it's a question of the
I don't know the the intellectual
capabilities of of the of the people
between you know political parties or
whatever well is it is I wonder if the
divide in politics are uh perspicacious
individuals and cogs zombies NPCs you
mean in putting this out I mean the
decision to put this out rest with the
house no I mean in terms of the left and
the right oh is the left predominantly
followers and the right is predominantly
Discerning individuals I don't know the
answer to that I think you just got to
play the videotape and put it all out
there and let the online salutes do what
they do which is but I just get it but
you you take a look at what the response
from the corporate press is it's lying
no no I'm not disagreeing with you but
that's that's not new well sure sure
what I mean to say is are there people
who just lack the the capabilities to
watch the video you put out or will
their demoralized brains not allow them
to process that information as per Yuri
besman of I think it's a combination of
the two I think after six or seven years
of this some people just don't have the
capacity to process that something like
that could happen I think a lot of other
people will quietly in their little
group say okay we know that that
happened but when we go to the
microphones we have to say x yeah how
much of this 44 000 hours you think is
defect
I think look here's here's here's how
the security footage works right in the
capital having worked there
a lot of it is just going to be dead
time like empty rooms showing office
furniture
probably half of it to be honest with
you so now we're down to like 21 000
hours of footage still a ton of footage
right but that's I think 17 hours of
footage 17 000 hours of footage 1 700
days of footage so just to put in
perspective on how much it takes to
digest all that and I guess AI they're
able to use AI to split out all the
footage of non-motion so they can just
discard that I'm concerned that it's
going to defec the cue Shaman not him
obviously he's a little too public but
deep fake people blowing things up or
destroying things when they weren't I
mean obviously that's a malicious as
hell but I can hey don't count it out
you know we live in the United States
any they're capable of anything the one
thing the left and some of the media and
I hate to say they had a piece of it
right but the one thing they are saying
which I have to agree with is that there
are portions of some of the people that
were saying we're totally innocent where
there's actually videotape of them doing
something illegal like trespassing per
the criminal statutes or interfering
with police officers so that's going to
be the problem that if you do person by
person like you do the Q whatever this
guy's name is I don't think Chuck is
chancellor I don't think Tucker should
have started with that guy he should
have picked some guy that was straight
up innocent looked at all the videotape
on that one guy found out he was charged
with something you should never been
charged with and then started with him
this guy is just too divisive of a
character to do that with because I'm
sure the left's gonna come back and say
hey check out this video and I don't
know if this is true but check out this
video of him you know kicking a cop in
the or something I don't think
there's anything of that I think the
only footage that ever showed is him
just walking through and yelling at a
bullhorn
but it's the it's the it's the
iconography okay the weird hat thing
that he's wearing the face paint that's
why they they targeted him I think
you're onto something with that I think
the iconography of that of that day they
really really want the memes to be that
the at least for the left they wanted
the memes to be that it was a violent
you know serious thing anytime I talk
about it it's not odd that I get you
know pictures of that that miniature
um noose that they put up the miniature
Gallows the he wasn't even full size but
people on the left still think that that
Gallows was real and that was a real
threat and stuff so I think I think the
mean thing is totally right yeah I just
looked Jacob chancelly up just searched
for him on Brave and a group of some you
know three of the top 10 photos or him
screaming
like that's the that's the image I think
a lot of people are looking for is him
going ah yeah yeah yeah now you know if
you scream I think if they show
trespassing like non-violent offenses
they've served time that's time served
get them out immediately get them out if
they showed a picture of like some 50
year old dude with a big beer belly
holding a little American flag and
wiggling it and holding his baby in his
arms or something well I don't know if
he had babies with him but there's like
some some big fat guy just like waving
an American flag it doesn't it doesn't
have that same kind of vibe of some dude
with a crazy thing like that did anybody
take kids in that day
I don't think so probably though I mean
I would be surprised a lot of these
people were at a peaceful rally on the
other side of the building that had a
permit to be there and the police opened
the doors and let them in and Alex Jones
is yelling stop don't do it don't go in
the building if they're obsessed with
blaming innocent people for Crime
they're gonna lose it's going to lose it
can't it's not something why do you say
I'm not convinced because it's all the
data is coming out it's becoming
apparent like people are making fun of
them on the news with the people on the
left are doubling down and saying that
Tucker's lying that they're that it's
wrong blah blah blah and the average
Normie that doesn't watch a lot of this
stuff that has maybe you know an hour a
week that they can commit to actually
paying attention to what's going on in
politics they're still going to get
their news from MSNBC or CNN or whatever
and so I don't know that it's guaranteed
that just because this stuff comes out
your average person that is you know a
normie is going to be significantly
swayed now I hope that I'm wrong but I
don't see any real reason to believe
that this information
is really new you know I mean it's like
these are things that people thought and
assumed before I don't think that just
because there's confirmation on video I
don't think that your average soccer mom
in southern Connecticut is like oh man
I'm talking about I will support their
investigation if they let the innocent
people go if there are people blowing
breaking windows and kicking cops I want
them to serve Justice for that so they
want I'll join them and they're they're
Crusade if they let the innocent people
go this is why I was saying this moment
ago that I wonder if what really does
separate the political factions in this
country is
cognitive faculties
oh yeah McConnell was talking so slow in
that video earlier it's not just that's
like normalized it's it's you have
people who believe literally anything
the media says and no matter how many
times they're proven to be liars and
wrong they just keep doubling down and
I'm like that's a certain level of
zombism that you know a lack of higher
brain function you know like if someone
comes to you and says do you want to
stick a gum and then you're like why yes
I certainly would and when you pull it
out it snaps your finger with those
little prank traps they have and you go
well that kind of hurt that was a dick
move then you go here take another piece
of gum and then you go I don't mind if I
do snap ow man stop doing that well do
you want gum for real time yes I
certainly do but at a certain point it's
like what's wrong with you no he's just
gonna snap your finger again you're not
wrong there's still people who think
that we went into Iraq because there
were wmds there that's literally never
going to change for a certain faction of
the populace even though years later it
was proven definitively that that wasn't
even the case it wasn't even remotely
the case there are people that still
believe Donald Trump defended white
nationalists in the United I think it
was a Mark Twain he's also a Russian
asset don't forget that there was a guy
who went on MSNBC and argued that Donald
Trump was a Soviet asset like the Soviet
Union doesn't even exist right right
that was my favorite I I was it Jonathan
I enjoyed it to be to be to be fair what
he said was that Trump may have been an
asset of the Russian since the 80s which
would imply he was an asset of the
Soviet Union and after in the 80s and
after the Soviet Union collapsed the
infrastructure of Russia maintained him
as a as an asset for their uh that's my
favorite fan fiction that is my favorite
comic book story can you can we do like
we need a skit where Donald Trump is
like talking and then someone
accidentally says the activation code
and then Trump starts speaking Russian
yeah like someone that can do can you
imagine Donald Trump doing the uh yeah
yeah someone they can do a really good
Donald Trump imitation but speaking
purely in Russian
Trump in Russian yeah in Russian but
doing the important thing yeah
Mark Twain has this quote it's easier to
fool people than to convince them
they've been fooled yeah and he's a
smart he was a smart dude there's
there's there's a risk that like all
this information doesn't convince people
it just makes them say well I want to
pay less attention you know it's if you
make them feel stupid they'll withdraw
so you got to do it in a way that people
kind of empowers people rather than be
like you were so wrong look totally no
be like look how bet much better off we
are now that the truth is apparent let
me jump to this story from the Daily
Mail quote it rips our wombs wide open
family of capital cop Brian sicknick who
died the day after January 6 slam Fox
News and Tucker Carlson for using new
footage to downplay Riot and claim his
death was not Linked In the video
footage I don't know if they have it in
the article actually it looks like they
do let me uh we'll uh we'll mute this
real quick and then we'll play it
you can see officer sicknick is walking
around seemingly uninjured doing his job
telling people to move he walks over and
he grabs some sign of some sort and then
puts it behind a statue so he's going
about his business they initially
claimed the New York Times that what
what did they say that he got killed
with a fire fire extinguisher hit him in
the head that article is still up right
now in fact let me see if I can
see if I can find it
New York Times I I had the archive there
we go I saw it today here it is there it
is
he dreamed of being a police officer
then was killed by a pro-trump mob yo
this is definitively proven false how is
this article still up right now because
they're lying Liars look at this they
have an update that's all they have new
information has emerged regarding the
death the capitol police officer Brian
said like the questions the initial
cause of his death provided by officials
uh so how about you take down your fake
news well or leave it up but but make it
very apparent that this is an old
article that's been changed in the title
that that update should be in the title
well you guys are asking for way too
much this is that is unrealistic that is
never going to happen it stopped
happening seven years ago this is like
libless slander felonious like from yeah
in the day but a mob a mob can't sue you
right they have defamed a a pro-trump
mob as they've described it right they
haven't identified anyone exactly
they're like we didn't burn anyone we
just fed the fire so that's that's for
all you who are wondering how to defame
people and get away with it apparently
just apply them to a group so say like a
group of Philippines was seen punching a
dog or something and it's like I didn't
say he did it I said a group of him was
doing it yep
then my pronouns are they apparently
they so I guess here's the thing man
you're gonna no matter what happens no
matter what proof it's as Yuri besmanov
said you can show the demoralized person
proof and they won't accept it Ian just
mentioned I think you're mentioning it's
easier to fool the person or is that a
Mark Twain quote it's easier to fool
someone than to convince them that
they've been fooled the reason the
reason is fooling someone is is a simple
task of putting your trust in the wrong
person but telling someone they've been
fooled is to insult their ego and it
makes them recalibrate their entire
world view on the spot it's a challenge
depending on how much you know depending
on how much they have to recalibrate
their worldview if someone has a deeply
a deep conviction from when they were
like a kid ripping them out of them at
30 years old is going to be nine
impossible 100 but if somebody like
walks down the street and sees a dog do
a backflip and then you show them proof
that it was actually an Illusion by a
magician with a mirror they're more
likely be like oh I didn't realize that
and like if they've told 50 of their
friends that a dog did a backflip
they're going to be less like they're
gonna be more resistant yep realizing
they're a liar it's not just a one-off
anymore you're right it's probably more
than seven years ago but this has been
an ongoing campaign of disinformation by
the mainstream media I mean go back if
you go Russia gay Ukraine impeachment
one two Jan six the CCP balloon to bring
It full speed and then you talk North
stream too all of these people have been
lied to and lying in the media
consistently even though they were
proven wrong coveted Origins I was the
deputy director of National Intelligence
when we briefed Trump where the virus
came from and you know what he did the
next day band travel from China we we're
all Races four years later hey do you
guys know where the covet virus came
from the Wuhan left no
s but all those people
were lied to by the New York Times for
years and years and years think it was
somehow Trump engineered or related to
his you know ineptitude that we have
coveted on on planet Earth and this is a
carryover that they are able to just
forget and say okay what's the next
what's the next iteration of fake news
we can come up with so just speed
through what we were duped on so we have
a couple different types of people in
this scenario people on the left who
know it's all a lie yeah but are lying
themselves because they feel they're on
the right side of history or they don't
want to fight or for whatever reason and
the people who genuinely are just not
smart enough to ever see through this
and they just keep going on and
believing it which do you think is
bigger which like the stupid action okay
ignorant people I should I shouldn't be
so cruel I should say um
incapable of of discerning is it a lot
is it like 60 40 I don't know man you
know there was uh who's that comedian uh
Bill Burr is that his Bill Burr bald
dude yeah he was on Rogue and he was
like look Joe I I don't I don't know I
just turn on the TV they say put in The
Mask I put a mask on I just uh two weeks
later take it off I'll take it off like
that's the kind of person that's voting
Democrat they say I don't know I don't
want to know I'll turn the TV on and do
whatever they tell me to do at the time
so it's it's it's it's maybe I should
add a third person the people are that's
that's probably the people who know
they're being lied to don't care just
tell me what to say and I'll say it
because I want to go eat you know a
pizza at the bar with my buddies or or
watch football or something I don't like
not only you're right but I don't
there's I feel like most people are so
busy with like the real important things
of in their lives we do it here we talk
about how families are important we talk
about how you know go get away from the
cities that you know go have chickens
all that all the stuff you know meet
real people and at be active in the real
world one of the things that comes with
that is the responsibilities and that
means that you don't have the time to
sit there and be up to date on it and
it's it's a balance is I guess is what
I'm saying yes but Joe Biden gets
elected and you look at the charts and I
understand we're we're in the know the
the economic charts show that wages drop
dramatically right after the time Biden
starts signing these executive orders
and the uh what is it wages drop in
inflation skyrockets this means there
should be a real world translation that
we all know about that should be
impacting regular people to realize
things are bad that is under Donald
Trump or before the pandemic the best
numbers of Our Lives record low
unemployment the economy was booming it
was tremendous everybody agrees then Joe
Biden gets elected and you can't get
eggs
no no eggs anywhere now you're I don't
expect the average person to be like let
me go on my phone and look up why
there's no eggs I expect them to go to
the store and be like yo where the eggs
at something's wrong or why do they cost
so much when I can't or why are they six
bucks like what's going on something
inflation something's crazy it's the lie
but here's the issue these people like
do they not remember 2019 do they not
remember making tons of money and having
cheap goods and going out and partying
best numbers of Our Lives they forgot it
all it hasn't and now with all with
everything being bad you mentioned like
we're in the know but certainly there
should be economic dissent there should
be families being like why is my rent so
high why are my insurance rates going up
the it hasn't hit them yet though
because there was there was so the
inflation is still going up just the
other was yesterday the Fed was talking
about uh they're not gonna they're
probably not gonna lower the uh interest
rates the next time they get together or
they're probably going to raise them
again because inflation is not going
down as fast as they want a lot of the
reason why people aren't up in arms is
because the squeeze hasn't hit enough
people and it hasn't reached that
critical mass not saying it's not coming
it's just that it hasn't really got to
them yet I really don't think that the
average person has the real like the
real pinch where it's like oh man I
really need to stop complaining about
this and really get up and go do
something or else I'm not going to be
able to feed myself or whatever I don't
think that that critical mass is hit yet
yeah that's the frog in the pot boiling
scenario and they I have heard this lull
security false insecurity where they say
it's Putin's War that's causing the
inflation so I think people think if we
can just weather this inflation once the
war ends it'll go it'll be over yeah I
mean there's probably still people that
believe it's transitory that's one of
the things that the government has been
had been telling the population for a
year leading up to inflation getting
really really bad oh it's transitory
don't worry about it it's only going to
be short term every time that we that
inflation was brought up for the past
two years or past year or whatever the
the
Administration has downplayed it and
done its best to probably responsibly
keep the population from freaking out
but at some point they have to
acknowledge look it's going to be it's
not going to be as easy as it's not
going to be a soft Landing we're gonna
probably go into a recession probably a
serious one and until that happens I
don't think people are going to be like
oh you know things actually are bad what
do you think from a national security
perspective about inflation does that
concern you is it one of your when
you're big it is one of the non-sexy
items from a national security
perspective is inflation if everything
costs more than the defense of this
country costs more but the problem that
we have is we just print money to the
defense industrial complex and I'm not
saying as a former Chief of Staff at DOD
who paved the way for one of those
budgets and wrote a lot of those
contracts and funded them I call the
five big CEOs of Boeing earthwork
grumming and all those major producers
that we have McDonnell Douglas and I
said okay look a lot of the stuff you
make awesome provides an invaluable
asset to defend this country and a ton
of the stuff you make doesn't I've
literally seen you light billions of
dollars on fire so how do we strike that
balance right and that's the problem
when people don't know what inflation is
and then they just say oh it's a
trillion dollars who cares if it's 1.1
trillion no one ever actually really
cares and the people that care the least
are the defense industrial Compass
because they take the check back home no
matter what win or fail and to me that
is something that whatever whoever's in
the next Administration if you don't
agree to take on those monsters in the
defense industrial complex it doesn't
matter what the inflation numbers are we
are going to print money into a
never-ending cycle I also see inflation
affecting domestic security and that you
get roving bands of hungry dudes and
masks that go into restaurants and kick
kick tables over and grab stuff like
that's security we need individual like
local security as well which is a form
of Nano National Security the ground
swell that concerns you talking about
you saw the video that yeah another one
today of like 14 dudes and masks just
wrecking a place in New York and yep not
opening fire for some reason because
it's New York City I mean what is this
what is the story let me pull it up it
was it was it was just a video that I
saw and obviously inside there was just
a bunch of dudes just ransacking this
this establishment uh it looked like it
was Asian owned I don't know uh I don't
know any details I only saw the video I
don't know who it was or whatever I'm
not pointing fingers or whatever but
that's not that's not it but how do I
search for it I don't know I don't
remember who it was that that posted it
but it was another you know essentially
just another uh video of of people just
ransacking Andy Noe might have it
lawlessness I typed in mob to search
real life version of The Last of Us
Maybe
people's brains being routed by Fungus
and he knows been going hard on the
Georgia terror attack I mean that's
there's probably a good reason for that
it's so weird how I find myself becoming
more conservative just being in the
process well let's let's let's let's
pull up this story here from The Daily
Mail it's because of the left all these
stories The Daily Mail is where it's at
I mean they've written up every single
thing they've got photos of everything
when it comes to this story very few
Outlets are covering the antifa terror
attack poor little rich boy smirking
suspected anti-fagoon who helped attack
Georgia cop city as son of NYC plastic
Furniture Tycoon he and his 22 cronies
appear in court on terror charges so not
only are these people many of them from
out of state some International they're
rich kids yeah yeah but here's go ahead
no no I was gonna yeah good I was gonna
say this is another example of it ties
into the earlier conversation and
comment on it the biggest problem I have
right now is a two-tier system of
justice and that's the biggest argument
we need to advance not the Q Anon
Shannon whatever that guy's name is or
certain videos depicting X Y and Z but
use it as a vehicle to say look at how
differently you can be treated by the
justices in the United States of America
depending on your political orientation
go back to the antifa Riots of not last
summer but summer before that two uh
liberal attorneys
white shoe lawyers firebombed a New York
City police car and burned it to the
ground with Molotov cocktails and the
judge literally a good guy good guy
Federal so they were charged obviously
rightfully so as a federal prosecutor or
federal public defender who defended
people who did that stuff that's a
10-year minimum mandatory federal prison
sense you know what this doj did waive
the charges allowed the judge to go
under the mid-man and gave him basically
probation
that's a two-tier system of justice mark
my word it's gonna happen with this so
Ian just a moment ago said that he's
finding himself becoming more
conservative but I think the reality is
in today today's politics conservative
just means knowledgeable yeah yeah
because because like I'm not more
pro-life or anything right the opinions
of everyone in this room are not in
complete alignment on core policy issues
they're in alignment on the facts that's
it yeah it's the mobs attacking people
that I'm it's kind of my my main issue I
don't like that stuff I found that video
if you guys want to pull it up from
yalen I typed attack restaurant and
Twitter and it popped up yeah yeah how
do you pronounce it I mean how do you
spell that it's the Twitter account is
y-c-i-n-n
ew oh I found it yeah Tim to your point
we live in the lobby we'll pull that up
in a second we live in the logic of
Herbert Mark Hughes I've said this a
bunch it is it is we live in the uh the
logic of of the left is okay to do
whatever they want and the right must be
censored even at the level of thought
but how and and it's because people are
scared of the left yeah but yeah cash I
fully agree with you but how do we do
that I mean I guess since the dawn of
time I imagine the king's uh uh you know
enforcement arm doesn't prosecute him
because and as a leader when are you
gonna be like I'm under arrest you know
like no lead or whatever that I've ever
heard of would do that to themself
um but what what how would we do that
how would we prevent
multiple tiers of Justice from
coexisting and assessing okay it's a
massive overhaul one you have to control
the executive branch of government
install an attorney general in the
layers below him to eliminate
Prosecuting People based on religious
orientation or political orientation
like the rescinded FBI memo uh from last
week that showed that the FBI was
literally targeting Catholics in order
to do that you have to wipe out the FBI
I've always said this the best way and
wipe out the FBI I mean the FBI
headquarters component right the biggest
problem in government is these monster
headquarters components the FBI
headquarters building is the size of a
New York City square block what I would
do if I was FBI director in the next
Trump Administration is close down the
Hoover building and make it a free
Monumental museum for the Deep State on
how not to run government and allow the
world to go there for free I'm not
saying you don't need 50 people running
the FBI you do
but you take the 10 000 agents that are
stuck there and they're lawyers and you
send them into the field to investigate
child sex crimes bank robberies cartels
fraud and you do the same thing with the
doj headquarters building which is just
across the street and just as big why do
you need 5 000 lawyers in one place
telling you how to not do something or
how to politically motivate your bosses
and say and get them something that they
just I worked with all these guys all
these guys that are producing these
charges at doj for Jan six are literally
people that I used to work with who have
sent me subpoenas for January 6th
literally sent me to the Grand Jury
asking me about why I helped participate
in X Y and Z and I'm like dude I was
literally there with you Prosecuting
terrorists and you're doing this because
I've been labeled a trump guy and you
need to make yourself look good in front
of your boss you have to wipe out all of
this Personnel uh Charlie Kirk said the
similar thing about the RNC
decentralizing it getting that big
Central because what they do is they
have lunch meetings there then they go
over on K Street and they hang out and
they all had a little all that forms
because it's so easy but if they were
far away from each other then it becomes
a challenge to uh collaborate but you
also make people do like I every look 98
of the guys I served with at the FBI
want to go out and Chase bank robbers
and Chase down terrorists and take out
people who are harming children and
reduce the drug trade you know there's a
couple of Bad actors and you've got to
eliminate them the problem is they want
to go go after terrorists but then the
upper level like the top floor is
telling them that American like
Catholics are and they go along and
that's why you have to wipe out both you
have decentralized wipe out not just the
upper level that's it's not just the AG
and the director abolish demolish the
building you got to do the under
secretaries but and everything else if
these people are willing to go along
with it they're part of the problem I
totally agree and they shouldn't be in
there I mean this is the Genesis of my
book government gangsters which this
government won't let me release right
now but the whole point is you can go
out there
whether it's DOD nsaci FBI no and I take
Flack for this all the time and I'm like
yeah it is not an easy fix but there
used to be a day when the FBI was just
the FBI and doj was just the doj
prosecuting based on facts and law well
not politics and religion I saw a video
this morning
so uh I wake up and I what was it I
think I got I got a clip sent to me by
Sheamus of Freedom tunes and it's a
funny fouchy cartoon and then as soon as
the cartoon ends it rolls over to
another video of Police pulling over a
19 year old football player and falsely
charging him with a DUI and you can even
see after he blows the breathalyzer and
the body camera footage it says zero
zero zero
why did they do that why why did this 19
year old kid who was watching a football
game driving home who did nothing wrong
other than he had a headlight outside
his bright sun it's like a normal thing
it happens to people your lights go out
you're like well turn the brights on why
why
charge him with a DUI
and so the problem is
I see things like this
that a police officer falsely accuses a
teenager of a DUI but
and and
the police will run in Terror like
pathetic whiny crybabies when antifa
sets fire to their building in Minnesota
they won't arrest these people we can
watch a video of 150 antifa fire bombing
a government facility and of course
there there were 20 to 30 people getting
arrested but when you look at Portland
the cops just sit there and go well you
know go gee but you'll we see
why is it that we have too many
instances of police giving up BS tickets
and making false arrests but we don't
have too many videos of cops just
arresting antifa well now we at least
this thing in Georgia I love this this
is a situation I hate it because it was
a horrible thing to firebomb a group of
people to firebomb a police facility but
it was great that they responded not by
murdering people or not killing I love
them
issuing 35 arrests and charging 23
people like that's the way the covet
history is over for the most part now
it's like in fact I think in one city
the governor or the mayor Adams in New
York is saying take your masks off
before you go shopping I don't want you
going in there threatening thuggery he
said stores have to tell people to move
ironies New York City is saying take
your mask off I have to wonder cash if
everything I said before about people
being too stupid it's in fact that the
leadership is as stupid right of course
the leadership is no no the leadership
is evil they're not stupid there's a
distinction I've worked with all of
these people they are pure evil they the
only thing the Pelosi's and the schumers
and the and they'll like care about in
the world is being glorified in the
media that's it what's my next headline
what's my next payday how do I scam the
stock market with my husband how do I
come out on top and be speaker of the
house for more than basically a decade
that is the tract that people come in
behind them on and say I want to be the
next turn I want to be the next to him
they are evil that's the problem the
people that follow them yes stupid I
love that bit you met you mentioned term
limits earlier Phil before the show got
started do you think that would solve or
at least disincentivize evil term limits
on the bureaucracy
I I think the bureaucracy is the problem
I think that the the elected officials
are not I think the elected officials
are self-centered and self-serving and
that they do mostly do things to benefit
themselves I think that the bureaucracy
is where the real power is and I think
the bureaucracy is the biggest problem
in the United States like the head of
the FBI any of the any of the alphabet
soup uh agencies so your EPA your FBI
your CIA your your ATF your uh FDA your
all of them the reason is because they
make law they make rules that have the
effect of law with no repercussions from
the population from the voting
population so we talk about how it's
important that we're done you know we're
democracy but the people that make the
rules that you live by on a day-to-day
basis are almost always unelected so the
the government will decide we want to
pass this law and then whatever agency
that has jurisdiction over the law or
whatever the topic is they will make the
actual rules and the details to
implement the law so that's a whole
layer of legislation creation that the
population basically doesn't have any
access to has no ability to punish them
if they do something wrong so what
you're talking about is like the beef
patty of your burger yeah that's 100
Patty of the deep State I agree that's a
novel concept that a lot of people
aren't talking about the FBI directors
and CI directors all have term limits
they're gone with every Administration
right some should be shorter that's a
different argument but these people
you're talking about are the ones that
sit there and say I don't care who the
leader is I'm going to do what we want
to do what the political radical left
agenda is because it's the popular one
and they stay and convince the
leadership to do it and Goose it through
the system that was one of the biggest
problems in the Trump Administration and
one more thing to your point is it's not
just I understand and I agree that there
are evil people but there are there's
also something that Tim talks about the
banality of evil there are people that
just go to work and want to go and make
sure that they can go on vacation with
their wife and they want to just make
sure their kids can go to school and get
a good education and they come out of
school and they can get good jobs for
themselves and they just want to live a
normal life so what they want to do is
go to work and not make waves and you
know what makes waves voting for Donald
Trump or doing stuff like that you know
I want to jump to this next story but
before I do somebody super chatted about
investing in culture and that I've
talked earlier about how we have to
build culture and there's an idea we've
been thinking about someone floated to
us a while ago about giving a grant or a
gift of a large sum of money to a member
once per month and I thought you know
what that's actually a really good idea
so we're going to do it on a whim to do
what with though to like for Creative
cultural Endeavor oh cool so on a whim
just literally right now as I watched a
Super Chat go by I am announcing first
we got to check the legalities of this
but uh once per month if legal
impossible we will select somebody uh to
receive a ten thousand dollar Grant
towards a cultural Endeavor so that
means if you're working on a comic a
podcast a show music or something and
you're a member of the site then we're
going to work out a way that you can
submit and I I imagine we won't even get
that many submissions there could only
be like 10 people who end up saying like
hey I'm putting a comic together and
it's like hey get the 10 but the 10K
every month because they're working on
it but uh that's a good point I want to
see people build culture and that's more
important than anything I could ever buy
so if you're so the first thing I got to
do is talk to the lawyer in the
accountant uh because you might not be
able to they might consider it like a
sweepstakes or something oh I get it it
took me a year to stand up the
foundation because obviously right like
that and then giving away money this is
hilarious giving away money is the
hardest thing I've ever done why it's
impossible because they're they're
because they they will hunt you they're
concerned about tax evasion and stuff
like that they might argue that if we do
a thing where you have to be a member in
order to receive money then you're
you're in a raffle or something so we
might make it so that you don't have to
be a member at all but then it kind of
feels unfair to people who are
supporting us to not be you know so
we'll take a look into it but we will
start probably this month once a month
taking submissions we'll probably create
an email address for it and you can
submit like hey I want to make this
thing and then once per month we'll pick
somebody and say this is our winner for
the month send you a check for 10K to
start working on that and the
stipulation is we trust you please do it
if you don't well have fun with the
money you figured that out and at
Thanksgiving at Christmas time I'll
match your pledge that'll be cool yeah I
just we in order to win a culture where
you need culture right I was talking
about this because bandcamp took our
music down I saw that yeah well I don't
know we don't know why they haven't they
didn't give you a reason nope just gone
and so but you play a certain song
recently or like just out of the blue
like one day we went to check we're
we're putting up a new song that we just
filmed the music video for in a few
weeks and it's gone oh three songs all
three charted on Billboard and they're
just wiped off of their website whoa and
so that's why I said the real thing that
threatens the woke and the establishment
is culture because you can't win a
culture War if you're not making culture
we can sit here and complain all day and
night you can complain as you're getting
swirled down the toilet but you make
something now you're inspiring young
people so fair point someone said invest
and I say okay all right let's do it all
right the Tim cast we may maybe we have
the uh maybe we'll figure out a way to
go through the nonprofit or something
whatever is the most legal and secure
wave dude maybe it'll just be me
personally giving someone a gift I don't
know we just got to make sure we do it
right so I'm not saying we I know for
sure we can because they might come back
and be like no that violates these laws
or you gotta file these paperwork so you
know one way I figured out through the
cash Foundation to do it legally we we
started uh this summer we're gonna fund
summer camps for individuals who want to
go to like whatever music art Sports who
can't afford it to you know go down the
cultural Road expand their Horizons is a
way to do it that's easy it's not the
ultimate solution you're talking about
to be as expansive as you want it to be
but I'm sure there's kind of a summer
camp to be the next Tim pool if we could
maybe we should create one of those yeah
yeah yeah the challenge with uh just
giving money away is that there's no
guarantee it's going to do anything for
anybody that's true too you know so it
may help someone get better equipment
and everything but if they're not making
something that functions you know so
we'll try and pick the best people maybe
if you're working on a board game you're
working on a uh songs or something like
just something that will be fun and
expand the culture in the right
direction we'll start investing in that
what about you and cash and someone else
that can invest do your own version of
shark tank but for cultural stuff I mean
we had the idea of doing a non-profit
Shark Tank yeah like you know people
come in and some and at request
donations for their charity let me let
me be the host I'll be like the Heidi
Klum done let's let's let's let's let's
do a cultural Shark Tank thing all right
yeah all right today on Shark Tank it'll
be my cheap voice I love that deep voice
do you know how many people would watch
that it'd be hot it would be a bazillion
people yeah turn that on to be like
forget all the garbage TV you are
actually helping Young Americans or just
Americans in general Advanced novel
ideas and culture and
who who are some rich people we know who
we can rope into this and I got a few
but I think that I'll be down I mean
there's a lot of people who are
libertarian moderate post right role or
whatever conservative who are like we
need to win the culture war and so we
need to just scatter shot if we could
get a hundred people every month working
on cultural Endeavors wow sooner or
later one of those things is going to
hit and then when it does you've got
culture building in the right direction
and that's something more powerful than
what the left can do not to mention
you're going to get a lot of young
people who are like look my real
opportunity is going to be over here not
Hollywood because Hollywood is is
elitist and these guys might actually
give me the Grant I need to make the
comic book I want to run yes well thanks
to Super Chatters I think it's a I think
it's a good idea so okay we'll do this
we'll explore the 10K timcast gift or
whatever it needs to be legally if we
can if we can't I don't I want to make
sure I'm careful how I say this they may
not let us do it uh but if that's the
the case then maybe we just do a show
that's like a shark tank but for for
cultural Endeavors and then we ask
people to come in and Pitch us your idea
I think it would be funny if for the
most part people come in just always win
it's like we brought them in because we
like what you're doing so like I'm in
here's money go make more of this there
you go you know and so then it's a
feel-good show you know yeah like we act
like we're gonna I I don't know if I'm
in but I'm in yeah you know something
like that but anyway we'll elaborate
maybe uh closer towards uh the Super
Chat I want to go back to the cultural
stuff we're talking about and tell you
why take a look at this video that Ian
just told me to pull up it is yatin Chu
says this video is going viral on WeChat
fish Village a restaurant in College
Point Queens was ransacked by a gang of
masked kids and hoodies we've fallen so
low that there's no expectation of
consequences for this horrific attack on
private property and uh here's the video
foreign
[Music]
just a bunch of people in masks and
hoodies
they don't take anything they didn't
take anything they just destroyed all
that's all they did you have no property
rights in New York City wait did any of
these guys get arrested of course not
come on
look look I'm assuming they didn't get
arrested but why would they get arrested
it's New York true true I was just I
guess I was still hopeful but you got
Eric Adams saying stop wearing masks and
doors because of this stuff or he's
telling businesses to make people remove
their masks why would anybody open a
business in New York it's already gonna
cost you um it's gonna cost like
literally you probably need at least a
million dollars to open a business I
imagine and then you're gonna have
people ransack it the cops aren't going
to do anything if you if someone attacks
you and you defend yourself you're gonna
go to jail there is nothing at all
attractive about New York there's this
old this old Trope an old joke about
someone buys a house in an area and then
they go out and they hear a gunshot one
day and they panic and they you know
they they look outside and there's a
neighbor standing in the yard and he
says he waves them off and they come
outside and did you hear that he goes no
no don't worry about it you know once a
week or so I fire one off to keep the
property the property taxes low like
there's an old joke about that or
something like a TV show yeah there's a
tick tock that's what they're doing it
feels like what's happening in New York
people are fleeing wealthy people are
fleeing and we already heard from de
Blasio a while during the pandemic he
was going to buy up these buildings for
pennies on the dollar and convert them
into government housing
so it is what's happening being allowed
to happen so that the property values of
New York collapses so the state can
seize it all up for pennies on the
dollar and then there might credit might
be elements of it I think it's
overwhelmed I think that the the law
enforcement's overwhelmed I mean just
the group of how many are there 18 15
people like even they're probably half
of them are armed I don't know I guess
the New York City Police Department is
like the sixth largest army on Earth 34
000 34 000 police officers they're not
outgunned oh yeah they are 30 000 versus
17 million people no no no talking about
against yeah but that would be that 17
million people were criminals they're
not like the number of criminals in a in
a city matters because like the people
that are committing crime are the people
that continuously commit crime the
reason that people their crime goes up
or it's been going up is because they
let people that are criminals out of
jail to commit more crimes yeah that so
look I'm a New Yorker and a bunch of my
buddies on the NYPD and I served with
them when I was on the joint terrorism
task force what they're doing now is
they're literally standing there because
they're not allowed to go and make these
arrests they're not allowed to go and do
these searches and everybody has body
cams and they have to be on at all times
and they're not allowed to go do the
basic police work the stop and frisk and
they can't stop people like this because
they know the attorneys the attorney
generals and the State Attorney
General's offices will Chuck cases out
that they bring like this because it
doesn't meet a specific narrative it's a
compounding effect this is why New York
City is terrible now it's not the New
York I grew up in back in the day and
people don't want to go over there
anymore that's why people are leaving
they're moving to Florida and Texas and
wherever Idaho West Virginia yeah you
know I heard that's the best place to be
yeah we've got uh some new friends who
are in New York for a while they're down
in this area now and so it's it's close
enough to a bunch of airports West
Virginia itself is still this beautiful
mountain country but if you drive north
a couple hours you're in Pittsburgh you
drive to the east couple an hour or so
you're in DC and go South to Richmond so
there's there's urban life you know we
can fly people in that's not there's
opportunity out here but people are
leaving the city and I have to wonder if
it's on purpose that's that's the point
we talk about how they're not allowed to
arrest these people and that's that's an
interesting question
why would that be the case what does the
city gain by telling police not to
arrest in charge it's a it's a
combination narrative it's not a one-off
the the the left set out to have an
opposite of a law enforcement agenda
they said no cash bail we are going to
let everybody arrested even for severe
felonies out on the streets we are going
to let illegal immigrants uh charged
with other crimes and then we find out
we're illegals we're not going to detain
them we're going to release them when
you do all that and you bring in people
to the justice system and you tell your
prosecutors we're not going to charge
low-level drug offenses we're not going
to charge low-level robberies it's a
compounding effect that basically says
to low-level offenders you're going to
get away with this and even if you're a
medium to Serious level offender there's
now a 50 50 chance no one catches you
and if they do the charges might get
dropped so what do criminals do become
bigger criminals and that New York City
San Francisco Chicago
last year
literally had a child under the age of
five shot a month one child under the
age of five shot a month and killed
that doesn't happen in any other City
unless you're in Lori Lightfoot who just
got the boot because they said we are
not going to take on gang violence we're
not going to take on gun crimes and when
you're arrested for one of those you're
right back on the street we're not doing
cash bail and there's theory that goes
along with why they don't do why they
want to not prosecute right so the to
the left people that commit crimes
they're victims of society's
circumstances so if they're a victim of
society's circumstance and they carry
out a crime and they victimize someone
else if you punish the person that
carried out the crime you've literally
made two victims you've double
victimized them so they victimized the
person that they attack or whatever but
they're already a victim of society so
if Society punishes them they're a
victim again so Society is victimizing
them over and over and it's it's
creating more crime is according to the
left now I think that is a load of crap
but that's the that's the the philosophy
and the theory behind the idea of no
cash bail let people out of jail if
they've committed Petty crimes Etc so I
mean whether or not you believe that
theory or not that is the the working
ideology and why the policies are being
implemented the way they are and the
Genesis was this farce that they were
somehow trying to solve a racial
inequity in the criminal justice system
by saying oh this is unfair to black and
brown people
um so we have to do a total 180 on
supporting anything Law and Order you
don't have the hypocrisy of it all is do
you want to know the two individuals
have put more black people in prison
than any two individuals in American
history Barack Obama no Kamala Harris
and Joe Biden Kamala Harris when she was
the Attorney General of California in
prison more black men than any attorney
general in the state of California's
history Joe Biden implemented wrote and
drafted and passed the 98 crime bill
which imprisoned more black men for
cocaine and crack possession than any
crime bill in U.S history was that 98 or
94 90 98 oh yeah and then didn't uh
Trump worked on uh Criminal Justice
Criminal Justice Reform actual reform
actual reform that's funny and he's the
racist guy he's a racist like Joe
Biden's been in also he employed some
odd years Trump employed a brown guy so
he's a racist guy oh yeah well but you
know you're the I'm the token white guy
no the uh are you are you Indian is it
I'm Indian yeah the Indian face of white
supremacy yeah let me make sure I got it
right Larry Elder's the black face of
white all right that's true I like that
[Laughter]
it's look anyone who who pays attention
knows that there's a meaningless
statement but the fact that someone
Falls for The Narrative of Larry Elder
blackface of white supremacy it's like
if you're gonna fall for that I don't
know how we how we communicate with
these people and affect change you can't
well they're voting what do you do you
got to be a beacon a lighthouse but
don't shine the light directly in their
eyes because of the line never caused
them pain you got to just be there for
when they need you you need to we need
to get the ideologies out of the schools
I think I think one of the reasons for
going up to schools is to make sure
people are so stupid they will always
just vote 100
absolutely 100 the more time you spend
actually thinking about the Dynamics of
Oppression when you're in math class the
less time you're spending on math and
history yeah that's literally the point
like they want to have generative issues
they want to have issues that teach
Politics as opposed to the topic they're
supposed to be learning and eventually
that will turn into like buildings
falling down in your society and planes
not getting off the ground and Chernobyl
yeah you need for math it's a language
you need people that are like
autistically observant of math it's not
diffused not like distracted by anything
really a bad home life people telling
you you're racist because of your skin
color like you need to be able to do
calculations and build buildings good
point real life translation of math is
architecture it's acceptable to teach
politics and have kids learn politics
but it there are you don't want to do it
in every single class and that's what
the influence of the left is doing
they're using they're using math and
they're using English and they're using
uh you know whatever whatever course
they can to generate political questions
that's the whole reason with the the
LGBT issues in school they use that to
generate political questions among
children so they can teach kids
political ideology I'm a core DeAngelis
has been uh school choice is popping off
I'm trying to find some tweets from him
but uh something big happened now we've
got 26 to 8 vote in Arkansas Senate
passed the governor's Bill to fund
students instead of systems according to
Corey DeAngelis passed the house 78-21
goes to uh Governor Huckabee that stuff
is that stuff is good and it's it's not
a bad thing but you the problem that's
going on in our schools now is in the
schools of education so it's all of the
teachers so it doesn't matter if you're
going with a this school or that school
if you're going to the public school or
you're going to the private school if
they're all getting teachers that went
to the same schools you see the problem
it's if your your schools of Education
your schools that teach teachers how to
be teachers if they're teaching teachers
to use the methods that are that are
critical theories essentially then
that's going to be put into all of your
schools so whether it's your private
schools your public schools whatever
they're all corrupted the smart fund
homeschooling as well if someone wants
to teach from home they get 13 000 a
year granted or something I'm not sure
but hopefully it does let's jump to this
story we got from timcast.com daily wire
investigative reporter to resign citing
inflammatory statements on
transgenderism I'll give you the quick
version this is Christina buttons of the
daily wire announced she was resigning
because Matt Walsh was mean and that due
to his inflammatory comments on about
Dylan Mulvaney there were people who
were good people and not gender
ideologues who are trans who are
receiving a lot of heat from this and
getting attacked and thus Christina
button's argument is you've got to try
and persuade the medal and convince them
to come over whereas Matt Walsh's
argument is you have to humiliate and
denounce and belittle your political
enemies this is interesting because uh I
completely understand the argument from
Christina buttons but I'm going to go
ahead and side with Matt Walsh on this
one
I've been doing this for too long I've
been in politics my whole life cultural
politics like activism and stuff like
that and I used to work for non-profits
and I learned a long time ago this is 13
years ago
man maybe even longer than that 14.
they're all lying these people are evil
people at these non-profits these big
ngos they claim to be big
environmentalists they're lying to
people for money they will claim that
they'll say things like oh are our poor
homeless shelter is filled to the brim
with homeless people and we need money
from you so that we can expand and then
you actually go and look it's completely
empty and they say well no one really
wants to be here because you can't take
drugs when you're in the homeless
shelter so we just tell people that I'm
this is the kind of thing that they pull
off plus you need six figure salaries
for every board member well I mean I
mean the people at the top are getting
paid fat cash depending on the size of
the nonprofit and so Matt Walsh comes
out and says you know we've got to be
mean to the people who are committing
these problems I don't think anyone's
saying be mean to trans people
necessarily there's I take it as a
reference to corrupt individuals who are
evil so previously in the show we were
talking about on the left you have
predominantly evil people who know
they're lying and ignorant people or
people who lack the ability to better
understand people being take advantage
of more or less we want to denounce and
be mean to those evil people
otherwise I see stories like this and it
makes me think this is why we lose
because we just played a video of people
ransacking a a restaurant in Queens we
just played a video uh uh I played a
video this morning of 150 antifa
storming into a government facility
firebombing construction equipment
the left Rules by fear and violence and
the right can't even manage to say a
naughty word
you know I don't want I think it's
better to not not to be mean to evil
people but to control them so that they
do what you want them to do like they're
mob mentality so it's easy to manipulate
them and it's you're better off being
kind and then them trusting you so that
you can control them here's the thing
how do you control Nancy Pelosi
become friends with her grandson I don't
know you get through the family you know
you get to connect them on a familial
level
for real yeah that's how you win culture
I mean let's be honest you make a song
that manipulates people to sing and clap
and like it's all manipulation
I don't know about that I mean
manipulation is not necessarily evil
manipulation is just moving things
around with your hands it's it's
controlling and manipulating society and
people and behaviors and machines and
all that stuff I think it's a fair point
for for me and we want to manipulate the
culture in a positive direction that's
absolutely that's fine but I think I
think some of what you're saying at
least a central theme in my opinion of
what you're saying the reason this is
the way it is is because the left no
matter their differences they always
unify hardcore on whatever is their line
of effort or their messaging campaign
for the week the month the year
conservatives Republicans whatever you
want to call them on the other side
don't we are always a divisive faction
even when we know
what everyone else in our group is
saying is correct for some reason we
have a personal Petty difference with
them and they go out and launch in in
even bigger opposition than the radical
left does let me show you the story from
the New York Post
New York Magazine art critic Jerry saltz
calls for shunning friends and family
who vote GOP so let's compare and
contrast the two articles in one a
report of the daily wire says I refuse
to work at a place where they're mean I
quit and then on the other hand you've
got the New York Magazine critics saying
shun your friends and family if they
vote in ways you that that you're
opposed to you see the difference in the
in in the culture War here yep you know
so when Matt Walsh comes out and the the
meanest that Matt Walsh was we said you
are you are Eerie and pitiable and
unearthly you look plastic I'm like he
didn't cuss
it was just kind of like
a slow downward description of an
individual it was it was insulting but
it wasn't the most insulting thing he
would not win a rap battle by that
nobody would be shocked you know but it
was mean right
meanwhile so so you've got tons of
people who are critical of Matt Walsh to
varying degrees for being mean for
saying this yeah Matt Walsh said you are
Eerie you are off-putting when people
look at you they will see something
pitiable and plastic and it was like
that's how he said it and that that's
unacceptable the right will not accept
that I won't allow that that talk is
mean meanwhile the left is like
you firebomb a police car and the judge
says you're a good dude that lawyer who
fired by the car the cop was like well I
know you're a good person at heart so
you know we're gonna give you a slap on
the rest here yeah or if you're a la
you're a lawyer in the FBI and you're
anything but pro-trump you can go live
to a federal judge be convicted as a
felon not go to prison and get your
legal license back who's that who are we
talking about Kevin kleinsmith yeah
yeah he he altered the email right the
the yeah oh yeah real quick for those
that don't know the critical email when
I was doing the Russian gate
investigation was Carter page is a
Russian asset sounds really sexy and be
like oh man we really got to follow this
guy well it turns out the FBI knew the
entire time that Carter page was helping
the FBI and the CIA productively not
being spied on and the lawyer at the FBI
Kevin kleinsmith literally took a
document and changed the verbiage and
then gave it to a federal judge saying I
need a warrant Carter page is a bad man
but we have all this evidence of him
actually helping the United States of
America do you guys remember all those
stories that we've seen over the past
few years where a liberal has announced
that they're leaving the left because of
antifa firebombing police vehicles tons
of antifa being like I will not be
antifa I can't believe they were saying
those mean things those conservatives
yeah it happens all the time right yeah
literally terrorists and I I remember
that viral video of the anti-foot guy he
comes out and he goes I didn't realize
they were going to be firebombing
buildings the so the joke obviously is
that that's never going to happen it's
never going to happen there are it's a
pipe dream there are liberals who are
like I was never really involved but now
that I see what they're doing I don't
want to be involved in that but you
don't typically see although it happens
sometimes but you you don't see a
circumstance in which an antifa guy
shows up to an antifa rally and then
leaves saying I didn't realize they were
going to throw Molotov cocktails they're
they're down for it they're all down for
it so what do you think the
justification of the reasoning is say I
don't know if you saw this but the
Russell Brand clip on um Bill Maher was
it Bill Maher yes whatever it was where
he basically blasted
we talked about this a couple times he's
wrong Russell Brand is completely wrong
I I should say completely wrong it's a
little a little heavy he's mostly wrong
he's partly right he said MSNBC is like
the same as Fox News they're just as
biased News Guard rates Fox News as
credible but pretty with caution and
they rate MSNBC as crackpot BS
okay so when you get an independent news
agency that's like the New York Times is
the Bastion of Journalism the gray lady
and ABC News and CBS and the Washington
Post are 100 certified and MSNBC is
crackpot nonsense don't trust them and
Fox News is okay and it speaks to your
point or it speaks to the broader point
that we're making when Russell Brand
just saying this is looked at as serious
pushback when you and yet at the same
time when you look at the actual facts
like News Guard and stuff like that it's
like well maybe maybe he they aren't the
same but just the pushback that Russell
gave is enough for people to be like
yeah man he's right because it's so
skewed the challenges are
you know I understand the idea of saying
MSNBC is like Fox News because I've I've
said similar things to friends and
family alike if you know somebody who
watches MSNBC use newsguard show them
that they say it's fake news conspiracy
and dismiss them as conspiracy theorists
and and and equate them with what they
associate as conspiracy so I I was
talking to a friend and they were like
my family only watches MSNBC I can't
talk to them about any of this stuff and
I said next time you're you're over
there just say something like I don't
watch this conspiracy stuff I don't know
you guys this is weird stuff and then
when they say what do you mean it's news
be like with the Alex Jones stuff like
is that what you're watching equate them
with what they dislike they will so they
can understand what you're accusing them
of doing and then when you're like well
I don't know what he does isn't that
what he's he's not on that one no look
then you can pull up News Guard and say
see look it says your fake news uh you
guys you you got to understand this
right so I understand the argument from
Russell or I should say in favor of
Russell's statement that for people who
think Fox News is completely fake
garbage nonsense you're equating what
they do with what they view as fake
garbage nonsense maybe then you can step
them in the right direction towards
actually watching Fox and realizing you
know 95 percent of Fox News is really
boring straightforward news and the only
complaints the left has is like Hannity
and Ingram well they really don't like
Tucker for sure but that's just because
he's influential but it's like the the
opinion stuff they take issue with the
news reporting at Fox News is news MSNBC
doesn't have news reporting it's all
nonsense
it's all narrative it's all it's all
exactly what the narrative the the DNC
and the left want to put so that's what
it is so I think from a from an honest
perspective
any objective view of Fox News would not
equate it with MSNBC
so that's where he's wrong I agree with
you on that but the fact that guys like
him and Bill Maher are actually going
out there and basically taking a
sledgehammer to a piece of the radical
left-wing agenda for putting out the
dumb narratives that they put out I
think is a step in the right direction
whether they're never going to go all
the way because they're going to come
out and see Fox News is the greatest or
whatever conservative republication is
amazing but at least they're calling out
their own bozos but maybe they need to
maybe they need to you know look man I
think Joe Rogan should have endorsed
Donald Trump in 2020. well I think he
should endorse them in 2024 but he's not
going to that's not maybe in 2020 I
think it was 2020 said something like or
maybe it was after he said I wouldn't
vote for Joe Biden because he's he's
broken but I didn't vote for Trump
either now recently Joe said I would
vote for Trump before I would vote for
Joe Biden which is a little bit of a
step in the right direction you really
think that he's gonna go all the way
over I wouldn't if someone came to me
like if Joe called me up and said look
man here's the truth I really did vote
for Trump I'd be like oh hasn't
surprised me at all but I don't I if he
says he didn't then I believe him that
he didn't just got no reason to lie or
anything like that I just think anyone
who's honestly in this space and
especially look man I go on I went on
Rogan's shows like a year and a half ago
now it was like November year and three
months uh four months and uh we talked
about Ivermectin and I said I I don't
think it does what you know the right
things it does I think that there's a
tribal perspective on all of this and
they want for there to be some kind of
treatment that's natural it it fits but
but I but I just don't know and look
I'll I'll admit I'm not a doctor so
don't look at me I'm not a scientist
I've just looked at a bunch of stories I
think the mainstream media is lying
about most of it they call it horse
space that's BS but Joe was the other
direction Joe was definitive like no he
thinks it works it's all in yeah and I'm
like if that's where you're at you're
further than I am in terms of
distrusting the media and calling it out
why wouldn't you vote for Donald Trump
like certainly you understand and you
know I'll tell you why I didn't vote for
Don last time because of the covet
handling the way he handed the keys to
the Anthony fauci and was like Hey
medical community do whatever you want
to the human race that's like Dude
You're our last line of defense as the
president that's we need you to protect
us from corporate malfeasance and the
pharmaceutical industry if there was
ever a malfeasance industry after the
opioid crisis you would wonder I mean
that's the one the military industrial
complex is up there but I don't know and
you cannot speak for him I know that but
I'm asking you since you worked so
closely with him what was the what was
the process wow this is when I go on the
road and do speaking engagements this
comes up every single time and I was so
okay rewind the clock covet's jumping
out I'm deputy director of National
Intelligence in charge of the
intelligence Community doing the
presidential Daily Briefing going to
brief president Trump saying this is
what we think happened this is where we
think coming from it came from what do
you want to do ban travel from China et
cetera right
and what we didn't have Fidelity on a
lot of fidelity on was what to do right
what are we we are in the middle of a
once in a century maybe two Century uh
play and half the world is screaming for
us to come up with some cure vaccine
whatever you want to call it the other
half the world is saying let us live
just do what we need to do and what
Trump did at the time and if I think if
you rewind the clock and said we did and
I defend operation more speed I ran it
at Department defense when I was chief
of staff and I I defended it because I
said we didn't make it mandatory we gave
everybody an option and the only
logistical component on planet Earth
that can roll that thing out into speed
with which we did was the dod
and I think he was right to make it an
option do I think had we the evidence we
do now we didn't know fauci was like a
Serial liar and hated everything we did
and would just literally suppress
evidence it's like this memo that just
came out this week we had no idea had we
an inkling of that we probably wouldn't
have listened to it but look at it this
way what if we were back then kovitz
running rampant and we do no vaccine we
just sit there we say wear Mass do your
ventilator thing which turned out to be
another fake line of effort and do
nothing it I don't think it was a win
either way but I do agree with you had
we had the intelligence we should and
would have done it very very differently
I think Trump trusted too many deep
States deep State Stooges
yeah fauci right I mean that's Mark's
fouchy I mean bring on Bolton was mostly
a mistake I say mostly because there's a
fair point that I can't remember who
brought it up that when Trump went to
negotiate with foreign world leaders and
they saw Bolton or heard about that
Bolton was on they panicked and were
like whatever you say Trump please don't
blow us up I mean I think it was mostly
Trump and not Bolton I mean I was in
there I worked for Bolton for a little
bit um the reason he got out he got
ousted was because he is exposed to be
an actual deep Stater but we just didn't
figure that out and we should have about
the falching versus of the world yeah
ahead of time and and that's the problem
it's not a great answer it's not it's
not what you want to hear you know from
your leadership at the time we wish we
had gotten it all right but if we had
come out and said don't take we have no
vaccine stay the course
live in your homes do nothing I don't
know that the reaction would have been
different from the other half was there
I I I real quick I want to add that look
no matter what the Trump Administration
did during covid the media was coming
for him oh yeah if Trump came out on day
one and said to the American people did
the address and says there is a real
risk of covid we are not sure what the
what the mortality rate is going to be
but it may be very high pay attention to
local news reports to figure out where
we're at and the federal government will
be tracking addressing this and
providing information but the choice is
yours keep that in mind as you go
shopping whether you will be safe
whether you will take treatment and talk
to your doctor and that's the guidance
we have for you if he did that then the
media would report it across the board
Trump abandons America
yeah he's doing nothing he's doing
enough winning look and that covet is
the extreme example because obviously
it's the most impactful for everyday
lives around the world but pick whatever
national security issue I was working on
Trump was always on the wrong side I was
in The Situation Room heading up
counterterrorism when we killed baghdadi
which I thought was the right move to
eliminate the world's worst terrorist we
wake up the next morning and CNN writes
an article saying why did you take out a
Muslim cleric what it was it was it
baghdadi that they called an austere
scholar watch that post yeah
that's the like it doesn't matter what
the issue was had we taken them out had
we not taken them out they would have
woken up the next day and say why didn't
you take out the world's worst term
you're 100 right but I I want to I want
to ask you excuse me moving forward like
so say he gets elected right my biggest
criticism with Trump is the people that
he that he picked right and I think that
that's probably the biggest criticism
that most people are going to have I
think that he dropped the ball that a
lot of the the stuff that we're dealing
with with the quote unquote Oak people
and stuff like that I think that he
wasn't on he wasn't on the ball with
that stuff and I think that he would be
probably better about it but that really
will depend on who he appoints because
he's the president he's not going to be
doing that full-time even though in my
opinion that's the the most Clear and
Present threat to the United States
right now
um is that ideology what do you think
he's going to do if he gets elected
again and what kind what what you know
what kind of people is he gonna appoint
now because he he's already run through
a whole lot of deep State scumbags to go
through I mean is he gonna like try and
find fresh you know fresh blood to come
in and actually do serious cuts at the
at the federal and bureaucratic so
here's the good news and it's it's thank
you so much for allowing me a Shameless
plug for my government gangsters because
it answers all your questions it's on
pre-order government gangsters.com and
you didn't pay me to do that yeah but
look the Deep State cannot exist without
the fake news Mafia and the personal
that you're talking about and the reason
that I took so much time to write this
book was to answer these questions if
Trump wins again or anyone wins again
how do we get it right and it's
Personnel Personnel Personnel across the
board 100 but what you have to do is
identify what we talked about earlier
and show the person that are failing
this government and fire them it's a
complete falsehood that you can't fire
government employees and terminate them
it is a total falsehood of the radical
left you can eliminate them that's what
I want to say real quick it's not just
Personnel it's in addition to that the
removal of personnel yeah done 100 so
when I was at dni I fired 10 of the
workforce how did I do that that's a
start but yeah rookie numbers but I'm
just saying right that's a start that's
a that's a few thousand people but what
I'm saying is a it's a farce it's a
fictional narrative that they created
that you can't zero out these people
it's not called straight up firing but
you literally zero mountain of course 31
days not hard to do then you bring in
the bench and I will tell you from a
national security defense law
enforcement Intel perspective that there
are people through all runs of
government that want to serve that
America first mission as Donald Trump
describes it which I believe in and so
you have to install them and I think the
other thing and I've had many
conversations with Donald Trump about
this I said look Rod Rosenstein Chris
Ray all your guys Bill Barr your guy
Gina haspel your guy Mark esper I
remember being involved in firing some
of these people he has learned like he
he came in as a businessman and said
well maybe I should trust some of these
people in government and some of the
traditional Republican people telling me
hire x y and z now we know all the
people that are on the bad list on the
government gangster list like don't ever
talk to not only those people that we
fired don't take anyone else from anyone
that told you to hire those people so
not only do we have a definitive endless
we have a definitive out list and I
think it's it's going to give him a much
better footing and I also think you're
going to start seeing certain people
surround him that will be in another
Trump Administration that people are
gonna be like okay we don't have to
guess who's going to be the head of DOD
who's going to be headed NSA who's going
to have the CIA and I think maybe you'll
start seeing some of those outlines come
out this is just my opinion but this is
one of the things that I think that
Trump needs to get his people out there
talking about ASAP he's already admitted
that he's already committed to running
so he needs people out there talking
about fixing the things in the future
because he likes to look at the past and
talk about the past and and complain too
much oh yeah
let me if you're going to be you're
advising Trump advise them to just focus
on the culture War issues and the
political issues because the one thing
that we've talked about at least it's
true this is just me and so everybody
can tell me I'm crazy but when he goes
on and on about 2020 he lose me when he
goes to East Palestine and then buys Big
Macs for people that is the is the
biggest like it may sound silly but that
Big Mac thing the McDonald's gave like
in my view my favorability rating for
Trump skyrocketed like 15 points when I
saw that when he started totally agree
when he put out videos talking about
cultural issues and things he wants to
do favorability is going way way up and
I'm very much with Trump at this point
leaning between Trump and DeSantis last
year it was like DeSantis probably got
it for a variety of reasons because
Trump wouldn't shut up about 2020 but
now that we're starting to see this this
East Palestine stuff if he's stops
ragging on Harper on the past and starts
being Trump from 2016. he's going to
give me back or even Trump so you have
to what I say to everybody is look at
the last year right the last year and
since Donald Trump actually made his
announcement in November that he's going
to run for president it's getting better
what he's been doing on Truth social is
putting out policy videos how I'm going
to take on China how I'm going to defeat
the CCP what I'm going to do on the
border what I'm gonna do about fentanyl
what am I do about the economy Health
Care education policy substantive videos
not just saying oh Joe Biden's a failure
but highlighting the solutions for that
very specifically get him back on
Twitter I think that's a step in the
round that's probably not going to
happen I think that's a step in the
right direction why no Twitter though
it's a terrible we'll get to that let me
finish that real quick so if he does
those policy videos and then the biggest
juxtaposition I have is him going to
East Palestine when our current
commander-in-chief Joe Biden goes to
Western Europe and doesn't have Eastern
one Eastern Europe what doesn't have one
diplomatic meeting with world leaders to
end the conflict in the Ukraine not one
no you
money to double down and make Ukraine
the next Afghanistan for the American
people that stark contrast I agree with
you if Donald Trump does more of that
then he is going to sail into the
presidency why is he never going on
Twitter because Donald Trump has true
social that's my opinion I you know I
don't speak for him but I'm just but
they should they he should do a thing
where it's like a day later the truth
gets posted on Twitter or something
it may come to that but I just my
opinion is I don't and then what he can
do is if he posts a longer truth he can
tweet hey go to truth social check out
you know the longer video or whatever I
just want KO Vivi again I want a foreign
yes yeah not today I want to Federate
the system here's what I think I think
someone was drafting a tweet and then
either Trump or somebody accidentally
pressed send instead of cancel that's it
for sure I mean that was my guess that's
probably it's coffee with a beef
I'm gonna punish you after the v's right
before I love the F on the keyboard in
the 10 minutes when the show ends the 10
minutes between when the show ends and
the uncensored show begins cash is going
to just go into this long time the
secret of Kofi wear us to secrecy we're
gonna be
the reality is I know the two people
that know and and it still hasn't come
out yet the secret of coffee regarding
um the rhetoric on the 2020 election
that I know Don's been going through at
calm down it's funny Donald's been going
through like um I think the one good
message is to say you know if we're
going to tally our votes in secret on
machines and private private
corporations we need to open source the
code so that we know the machines are
tallying them justly uh rather than be
like what they did was it was wrong just
be like in the future we're going to do
it right we're going to open source
these softwares if they're going to be
used I'd like to see that I also had a
couple ideas paper and pencil well
that's what he said it's epic he wants
paper ballot voter ID and he said go big
on uh mail ballot harvesting whatever
the verb yes but it's just so hackable
all that stuff is hackable if it's in
paper they're like yeah I'll take your
thousand votes and trust me I'll make
sure they're all counted wink wink it's
never see the guy again except okay but
that's safer than something that's
nebulous and can't be seen yes it is
safer than proprietary voting machines
doing calculations in private when you
don't have access to the code it is
safer than that but it's equally
it's it's it's just as insecure from a
macro scale when you could have things
like blockchain reference nine
blockchains of voting reference where
you can verify there there isn't
currently the blockchain that's been
developed and tested that would make
people feel like it's safe you may be
able to do it like technologically the
technology may be there but just because
the technology is there doesn't mean
that you'd be able to implement it in
the real world and have the population
feel better I just wanted to say one
thing real quick Donald Trump should fly
around to a bunch of random cities and
buy McDonald's for people is it I mean
you should come out what makes you think
that's not going to happen I'm not
saying it's not gonna happen I'm saying
like he should I mean I'm loving it I I
yes I'm loving it very nice
it's just like Trump showing up with a
bunch of regular people who are all
smiling and happy to see him and he's
like let's have Big Macs you asked me I
think Phil or maybe it was Ian asked me
before the show you know why did you run
so hard
um on the Donald Trump agenda maybe oh
no that was me that was me and and
and the simple answer is when you're
with him uh my mission was now security
defense into law enforcement
he's that guy he's the guy that you sit
down with and talk about
um killing terrorists bringing home
Americans Safeguard America in a very
casual fashion but serious and no matter
what he's going to defend that to the
end and then you're gonna eat McDonald's
afterwards and it's just I don't know
how else to describe it he's not this
bombastic guy who goes over there and
like lobs people's heads off or anything
like that when he calls me and I talk to
him he still asks me about my mom and my
dad like every time like and then he
takes the time to like meet them I mean
I don't know that every president does
that with everybody else I'm just giving
you my experience and I saw him act with
my other friends I went on that universe
and that's just how he is all the time I
went to uh Trump Tower when he was
running in New York I've been there a
bunch of times they got there's pretty
good food there and ice cream and stuff
and so he's running and uh the media is
going crazy and insulting him and I was
at the ice cream stand or whatever or
like the bagel shop and I asked him I
was like have you ever seen Trump around
here and like yeah he comes down every
so often and I was like oh is he cool
and they're like he just hands us
hundred dollar bills and I was like yeah
oh really he'll just come down here you
go and give me 100 Bill I'm like oh
that's awesome and he said sometimes
he'll bring the staff out thank them all
shake their hands and hand them 100
bills that's very that reminds me of
like the gangster movie stuff from like
back in the day not that I right not
that I have like a personal experience
with it but it's like that's the stuff
look I've seen it when you go to his
properties whatever Trump National this
that or the other thing you're talking
about people who have been employed
there for 15 and 20 years and he goes up
to the the lawn care guys the kitchen
guys the maintenance guys and everybody
knows them on a first name basis and I'm
like okay that's not manufactured that
can't just be made up that has to exist
over a period of a lifetime and that's
how he treats people I knew a guy a long
time ago in Chicago and he said that
when when they were open in the Trump
Hotel in Chicago he was dropping
something off I can't remember what he
was doing but he he told me the story
that he was walking towards the door and
he heard people behind him and he gets
the door and he he looks he holds the
door open and it was Trump with some
people Trump walks through the door and
says hey thanks kid and throws him an
iPod and this is back when iPods were
expensive thing yeah but he was like
thanks for holding the door for me
here's a 500 MP3 player or something
like that he's he's done he's done all
here's the thing he'll never tell you
about these he could write a book about
all these things the media would
excoriate him but that's not his style
he's not like oh remember when I did
this this and he'd been doing it for 76
years that's why it's so crazy how
I mean just look I literally go to Trump
Tower in New York I just ask people and
they were like he's awesome and I've
been to Trump Darrell I stayed there a
couple times because it was near where I
was working with for Fusion same thing
everyone's like when he's here it's
awesome and I'm like huh then then why
do people like act like he's so evil I
don't understand media I think that's
because liberal economic order is trying
to turn into the world economic order
they're trying to create the New World
Order and they had a plan for the last
30 years he was like a wrench in the
gears didn't realize it I think you're
on to something there he's he's a
nationalist like he believes in America
like he's patriotic he's a an old school
Democrat that believes that borders are
a thing and the the modern left is
moving away from Nations they really
think that they can use things like the
U.N the world economic Forum the
international monetary fund to basically
create a super government that controls
the governments of the world and the
United States is not insulated from that
at all we should be and we can be and I
think a whether it be actually Donald
Trump or someone like Donald Trump that
believes in Nations and stuff
um I think that that a president like
that can
uh influence the the us but right now
the people that are running the
narrative and that are running the
country and dictating The Narrative they
believe in an international order that
should supersede individual countries
and Nations well I was as you were
talking I Bernie Sanders came to mind
because he's kind of a nationalist in a
way you know a bit more socialist than
Donald Trump but yeah everybody is a
nationalist socialist yeah he sure is
have you guys considered getting Donald
and Bernie together oh yeah on a daily
basis over you know ice lattes in the
market just patch it up because like
just I remember him being like Oh no
Donald Trump's bad bad I'll support
uh because I don't know why or anybody
run for president oh hell yeah dude
bring it on you see what just happened
today the other days asked by Bill Maher
about Equity versus equality and he said
uh I can't tell you the difference I
don't know it I don't know that and then
he was like I think I'm for equality but
and then Jack yuger comes out and he's
like of course he's for equality no
one's for Equity meanwhile like Joe
Biden came out was like equity every HR
department says Equity it's Placid in
every University so are like are they
retreating from this stuff now because
it's not popular that tweet by sink
younger is the most valuable weapon on
Twitter right now to push back against
the equity movement because he has
demonstrated very clearly the modern
Bailey argument the The Mont Bailey
fallacy he backed away into the no we're
talking about equality when for the past
five or whatever years everybody's been
Equity Equity equity and Equity means
good equal outcomes as opposed to
equality which means equality under the
law he has given a weapon to people that
are involved in the culture war that has
not been seen in a while but you don't
need to call it a mountain Bailey you
can just be like No Junk yoga agrees
with us the progressive Young Turks
agrees that Equity is the problem is not
where we want to be at and equality of
opportunity is the real goal and so when
anybody comes out and says Equity Bill
like equity aren't you a fan of Bernie
Sanders Bernie Sanders says equality not
Equity Jack Huger of the Young Turk says
he called Bernie is the dude Bernie said
equality not equity on Bill Maher and he
clearly said equality of opportunity yes
not equality of outcome look we won
there you go Bernie Sanders said it if
it's going to be his campaign slogan
don't get don't get uh when you're
arguing when you're debating family and
friends you don't want to be uh
acrimonious I'll put it that way you
want to be calm and just say you know
look look I know we might disagree but
I'm with Bernie Sanders on this one I I
I don't know if you're a fan of Bernie
Sanders but he went on Bill Maher and
said we don't want Equity we want
equality of opportunity ever in a debate
or discussion with someone that you know
long term and they offer you a seed a
seed plant the seed Let It Grow because
that will be a reminder in that
conversation forever that you guys agree
on something right I'm not gonna sit
here and be like jenk euger is bad and
Bernie Sanders is bad I'm gonna say this
oh I agree with jenk and I agree with
Bernie Sanders they are both 100 correct
equality is the appropriate response not
Equity but equality of opportunity
because Equity is equality of outcome
that's a different type of equality no
but yeah but but maybe they're abusing
the word look I'm a Bernie supporter in
this regard you know when he said you
know you guys might be Trump supporters
but when it comes to uh you know Bernie
Sanders come out oh I'm I'm there there
you go so now you can tell all your
Lefty friends that you're a Bernie
supporter because he said a quality of
opportunity Bernie charges 95 ahead for
his new book tour does he really yeah
just started good for him
capitalism it's called the it's okay to
hate capitalism too or something like
that yeah yeah
look look my point is just this uh take
it to a positive level and think about
the gifts you've been given you are
right Phil that it that what jenk said
is a weapon but you simply need to say
well don't you agree with Bernie Sanders
and The Young Turks on this one and then
if they say no and Bill like then who
are you agreeing with if not Bernie
Sanders like he's the dude right no you
don't think so what are you a Nazi or
something were you a Democrat like
Hillary Clinton supporter fascist no
what was it I'm the Indian Neo-Nazi no
the Indians
I want to ask about more about well we
gotta go to yeah we gotta go we gotta
move this along baby we're gonna go to
super chats my friends it is my birth
week Adrian Curry was like you get one
day well no it's it's look I have a
whole week it is the year of your birth
year I am going to milk it for all it's
worth to ask you all to become members
at timcast.com because it's my birth
week Thursday's my birthday but uh we're
gonna have a members only show with cash
coming up after the show it'll be live
around 10 10 p.m so uh check it out it
should be fun we'll talk a lot uh more
about what's you know what's happening
and uh what's going to happen when I'm
going to curse he's going to swear a lot
oh yeah but uh yeah become a member at
timcast.com go to timcast.com click join
us sign up Live show will be around 10
10. you'll see it on the front page of
the website but let's read your super
chats smash the like button and I'm not
your buddy guy says I wish you and your
crew the best of luck
personally I've lost hope in is a CA
Canada especially after they arrested
yet another Pastor not far from me you
know that song Mad World it hits too
close to home yeah it's Duran Duran yep
no no no no no it's uh not Duran Duran
Roland nor is the ball Tears for Fears
am I right Tears for Fears I believe yes
yeah and then the original solo album by
the way Tomcat screaming is incredible
incredible Rogue says Tim you need to
play the board game secret Hitler it's
extremely relevant today maybe you and
the crew can play a live stream game we
haven't and we've played it every so
often for those that aren't familiar
it's basically a werewolf game you play
werewolf nope werewolf is a party game
where everybody sits at a table and puts
their head down one person's a
Storyteller this uh they you can do it
with cards or you can write down tags
and then you get a certain number of
people are villagers and then one
person's the werewolf and then the point
of the game is everyone puts their heads
down the Storyteller says the werewolf
looks up
and then you know looks down or whatever
and the goal of the game is for
everybody to rise up and try and figure
out who the werewolf is and if they
don't the werewolf gets to remove one
player secret Hitler is a game where
everyone's given a role either liberal
or fascist
the only thing that exists apparently
and then uh the in order for the
fascists to win they need to enact a
certain number of fascist policies and
then for the Liberals to win they need
to enact liberal policies or assassinate
Hitler
and the way it works is you get a chance
to learn a president someone gets
nominated everybody votes or something
like that and then if the person gets
elect I think if Hitler gets elected
Chancellor or something's over yeah yeah
something like that but you you uh will
get three tiles and then you pass the
tiles the president pass them to the
chancellor and then the chancellor picks
one and then what happens is if you get
handed three fascist tiles
you know you're like uh oh what am I
supposed to do with this and you hand
two and the guy looks at you and he's
like why did you just give me two
fascist ones are you Hitler are you the
fascist and then you play and everyone
says why did you play a fascist one
you're like it was all I was given don't
blame me blame him and then everyone's
trying to figure out who's really lying
and who's telling the truth it's a fun
game there's a game called uh Mafia
that's very similar to that we I used to
we played that my buddies in unearth and
Madball when we were on the sounds of
the Underground Tour we played that all
over Europe it was a ton of fun dude I
love Mafia yeah it's the same game yeah
it's a different skin basically yeah you
can tap on the head and on the shoulder
to decide so you don't need cards or
anything yeah the bass player from uh
from Madball Hoya super nice guy and he
was always like yo let's go we're gonna
play Mafia yo get an odd number uh get
an even number so you can have an odd
number of players in one one game yep
all right jazzanot says Tim pool is
evolving into Alex Jones before us
we're turning the freaking frogs gay
yeah they're coming for your income tax
that'd be a fun cast Castle skit if they
could pull it off where you like
Incredible Hulk into Alex
don't go in the building we have to get
action we actually have to get Alex yeah
and then it's like you wouldn't like me
when I'm angry and then it's then it's
Alex who rips his shirt off I think I
would be down for it we're doing that
show in uh Austin with Luke Blair Alex
Stein Alex Jones Michael Mouse gonna be
a whole lot of fun should be a good time
that's April 14th April 14th yeah an
event sold out in like two days so yikes
should be fun though and there'll be a
follow-up Show April 15th that I'll be
at as well Theoden King of the brohan
says did you see that West Virginia is
portrayed as the heart of the
Confederacy in the new Mel Brooks
History of the World show every record
has been destroyed or falsified every
book Rewritten I mean I think West
Virginia is split off from Virginia on
purpose
West Virginia was pro-union and it was
when I was reading there's wind there
was a vote in West Virginia counties to
secede from Virginia but all of the
young men were away fighting in the war
so the vote was held by people who were
not fighting in the war that's how it
works I guess history yeah and then
Virginia only we learned that in school
Virginia sued after the war saying now
the War is Over West Virginia is
Virginia and the Supreme Court said nope
it's a new state shut your mouth now
it's best Virginia now it's about it is
best Virginia all right let's see we got
equal sign says Tim you and Ian
mentioned Magic the Gathering in poker
the other day ever heard of Aces and
Adventures it's a steam game that
combines the two you might like it thank
you we were actually talking about a
card game that uh combines elements of I
don't necessarily want to say poker but
uh a turn-based community board Magic
game that's focused on a single deck of
cards so that you don't need deck
building and it's a bit more random and
combines elements of deception so I
guess you could call it that but uh yeah
we're talking about I'll look at Aces
and Adventures would be nice if it was
an actual card game did you hear Ian
about the 250 000 of the magic cards
left in a dumpster no or in a landfill
sorry no boxes boxes of Magic the
Gathering cards were found just in a
dumpster and then the bulldozer
bulldozers smashed them up and just
destroyed them and everyone's like oh
that's so sad and I'm kind of like if
you think it's worth 250 000 pieces of
paper smashed in a landfill I got
something to tell you it's not worth
that at all like the fact that someone
threw it out and it was loaded into a
landfill proves it was not worth that
and I I think this is an example of the
decaying culture magic secondary Market
these trading cards with a lot of money
I think it's been corporatized and gone
woke to the point where they're becoming
worth less literally worth less not
worthless you know
we'll see though we'll see I've been
hearing nothing but complaints about
what Hasbro's been doing in the game so
that sucks used to be a big fan way back
says I already have a Tim cast
membership so here's an extra 10 bucks
I'm really looking forward to see what
Tucker says tonight it's going to break
the unit party's brains was he releasing
more video I believe so right
cool well we'll see I don't know
let's grab some more Super chats all
right and uh and where's Sheamus at for
that matter do you guys see he put out a
short on freedom Tunes a preview of the
upcoming video of for which I am doing
the voice of Dr fauci and I think it's
really funny so this one's got to be
really great on Thursday really excited
all right essay federally says surge is
full on Bolton bro today let the Bros
loose on your swatters what would Javier
Pena do
to Bolton Bros yeah shouts out rash has
Tim in earlier segments you talk about
the death of culture and while you are
building it maybe you should look to
invest in other people's ideas of books
and games through some Shark Tank style
pitch and that is from wrath hence I
discussed that idea after I saw that
Super Chat doing some kind of shark tank
type thing and uh yeah somebody super
chatted saying we'll need clear rules
and a judging criteria to award the
grant because it will be viewed as like
a sweepstakes or a contest and uh works
for me I think it'll be you know what I
was thinking we'll do why don't we just
do a YouTube show where we will like
take submissions have a judging criteria
maybe we can get as like five advisors
you know independent so outside of
timcast will come in and they make the
determination we don't but we then go
and film so let's say it's like you you
know and for other people cash you guys
say out of everyone we saw we think this
is the guy then we go film knocking on
the door with the check written out you
know printed out to the person for their
idea and then being like and that's a
show and then the show is they talk
about their idea you know we explain why
they won and why we want to succeed and
then we cross our fingers that we hope
you know it works out good luck a big
part of what makes Shark decorate is
when they will rip people apart with bad
ideas I mean it's very entertaining and
it makes that'll be your job it keeps it
honest okay it keeps it honest because
then when they are good they're not like
you know well same with all those dance
not dancing shows whatever that that guy
does yes um Simon yeah there you go yeah
something like somebody apart is like
people watching like some little old
lady will walk in and she'll be like I
just need some money so I can make my
comic book and Ian's just like this you
are terrible yeah you disgust me and the
church the Art's not even good
she like makes a batch of cookies and
they're like Trump face cookies and
she's like I wanna open a trump Bakery
and Ian's like ah he slaps the Trav
cookies in the air everyone that comes
on a show would get a guaranteed five
thousand dollars or something and then
you
I think what we would do is we would
request submissions then we would have
an external group handle the judging
criteria so we would not be involved in
who wins and then whoever they determine
is the winner based on how the outside
group votes we would then show up as
part of their submission process they
would agree that we can film them if
they win we'll shop their house and then
we show up their house knock on the door
and be like we got money for you
maybe we just come with cash and start
making it rain you know and that's
actually always good yeah and then you
have the machines from oh yeah yeah
where I will be tomorrow by the way
Brett and Mary show up and they're
standing there holding the the money
guns
but real dollars as opposed to the fake
ones real Hondos
yep yep
yeah I think we'll we'll look into the
legalities of it but probably an
external group judging that's intros the
camera comes down pans down with you on
a circular platform that's spinning
around you're like oh and the money's
shooting out at HBU like a genie it'll
be me yeah I'll be like the Ryan what's
that guy's name from I think it should
be called like Ian Crosslands cash money
gift show or something okay dude roll
with it yeah uh Ryan what's his name
Seacrest yeah Seacrest I'll be the Ryan
Seacrest on this one and you'll have to
explain why their cultural project
deserves the money
and then in order to deliver the money
to them you have to just hold the money
gun and spray them with it and be like
I'm sorry it's the show rules I have to
do it it'll take about 30 seconds close
your eyes it hurts less
and then we just film the person there's
like getting sprayed with money and it's
like sorry I know it's a mess but you
know at least you got ten thousand
dollars so yeah like
um Who Wants To Be A Millionaire that
real intense intro the lights go down
and then back up yeah we could make them
as we can make so I just look over the
monitor I say e and see Ian make
pretending like he's got the money gun
to a set we can make him answer trivia
questions a game show
oh actually that's a good idea too yeah
game show well one of the ideas we had
was doing a game show where you get a
liberal and a conservative and you ask
them basic news questions
that's good you could do that like a man
on the street kind of thing or are you
talking about that's actually true you
could be like for 10 bucks
you know question and then when they say
the wrong thing like oh sorry I mean
it's springtime in DC coming that's
great but what we could do is we get a
local DC resident and a local West
Virginia resident and it's like and then
you see who knows more about the news
you'll get some like mountain right wing
nut job with like a trump shirt and a
trump hat and then you'll get some like
buttoned up North Face jacket wearing
dude from DC and then you'll be like in
2020 Donald Trump said what about
neo-nazis and white nationalists and
then they write down their answer and
then the DC guy is like he praised them
and called them very fine people and the
D in the Washington and the West
Virginia guys like he said they should
be condemned totally you're like West
Virginia takes it and you like hand them
100 bill I think it's a great idea well
I I gotta be honest I firmly believe
that if you did a liberal versus
conservative trivia show the
conservatives would win every single
time I think it's probably hands down
100 like okay I'm being a little
hyperbolic it'd be like 80 20. probably
yep
all right let's grab some more super
jets super chats not regular chats super
chats and then also member chats Maybe
see what's going on the membership chat
as well
all right what do we got x-rayed says
Hey cash I'm getting out of the military
this year I can't take what it has
become I need become a part of something
that's pro-american what Avenue can I
take to be a part of what you're doing
go to fight with cash.com or the cash
Foundation we have ambassadors we have a
whole Myriad of ways we're helping
active duty people transition out
there's lots of jobs there and most
importantly we're trying to help
veterans and people who are homeless who
used to serve in uniform get back on
their feet so there's a ton of work you
can do and anyone can do just check out
the website you can buy this funny merch
which we are moving insane amounts of
units and all that money goes right back
into the foundation so
thecashfoundation.com right on brother
Mr Jarvis says I'm working on a podcast
as you're talking well you know here's
the thing though
podcasts are good podcast yeah what do
you tell him well well no I just I it's
like we can't just be complaining about
stuff you have to have Solutions it's we
so listening to a show that discusses
issues and culture isn't we need to go
beyond that we have a lot of those you
know daily wires got six of them Stephen
Crowder me you got 6X and Hammer you got
the Lotus Eaters podcast we're all
talking about this stuff and a certain
point we're like we get it y'all mostly
agree what we need is someone to make a
comic book I mean and we have that we
have ripaverse you know obviously you've
got people who are working on books and
music and stuff like that that's
important I mean Phil Labonte literally
sitting right here yes sir I have to and
and that's that's extremely important I
mean
storied career rock star Phil Levante is
sitting here doing the inverse of it
from making culture to commenting on and
so like creating risk for yourself in
that space as well sure I mean but in
and and and I appreciate the Kudos but
like you know making culture and making
music is still something that I you know
am actively doing where we've got the
next record I've decided I've already
decided on a a a title that you know is
intentionally not going to be something
that sounds super Metal but it's going
to be something that gives people hope
and I'm not writing songs that are that
are negative I'm not writing songs that
are are depressing our biggest record is
this record well arguably our biggest
record is a record called the fall of
ideals and even though it has kind of a
negative sounding title all the songs
that are not about chicks is which is
about half of it are about
self-empowerment like they're all
there's a song called the air that I
breathe and there's there's a song
called not alone there's a song called
This calling there's there's so many
songs about that and that's something
that I have done throughout my whole
careers try AI to write songs that
inspire people to believe in themselves
and that's something that I think is
important and hopefully that's something
that but whether you write music or have
a successful show or have a foundation
or what have you you put out these
ideals just prepare to be attacked
absolutely they're going to come after
you well that's the thing I mean you
know I imagine if you just keep your
mouth shut Phil you'd you'd have way
more people in music offering you stuff
but you speak out challenging the BS and
you put risk on yourself any of the any
of the politically
motivated people in the music industry
hate my guts I have lost friends most of
the people in there right well no there
are there are some people that are like
no I don't want to be political and
there are actually more people now that
are like yo you were right you know I
shouldn't we should we shouldn't have
been so hard on you or whatever blah
blah you know we should we shouldn't
have been pushing you out and stuff
um but there's so many people that are
ideologically motivated just like every
other you know part of our culture right
now there's just like we talked about
the FBI there are normal people in the
FBI and then there are people that are
extremely ideological that's the same in
the music industry it's a little more
heavily you know tilted to the left in
the music industry but there were media
there were blogs that were tearing me
apart in 2012 2013 because I had the
audacity to say things that like you
know communism's bad
what was your biggest song like the most
successful or there's two that are
probably our big two that are our
biggest individual songs there's a song
called two weeks and there's a song
called what if I was nothing both those
songs are about chicks I was I was I was
thinking that those are the ones I was
thinking of and I was like you mentioned
the ones that aren't about chicks I'm
like the ones about chicks the big ones
because they they they can relate and
also they're they're they're the songs
that I wrote about real things that
happened so they're very raw and so
people can really relate when I'm like
it's not like it was some kind of
abstract thing like they're both about
actual arguments that I had with people
that I really really really had very
deep feelings for so they're really raw
and that stuff tends to relate let's
read I want to read about the Super Chat
Dylan Hale says holy crap 10K that could
pay for my whole book series editor art
and all they've been working 50 hours a
week to pay for it all piecemeal an
opportunity like this would be
life-changing what's the best way for
Dylan to get in touch with us do you
think he could they could message you
Ian doubtful I mean you can you want me
to pass it on to somebody well I don't I
don't know how like
if yeah I don't know how to get in touch
with a direct Super Chat it's a
challenge like how could we how can we
how can we send Dylan Hale 10 grand for
his book well Dylan should submit a
business proposal and um to like is
there like a general inbox that you can
go pull it out of for someone to look at
no I mean we don't have anything set up
yet just to get information you can send
a DM my Twitter account that works yeah
okay DM me I'm Phil that remains on
Twitter send me a DM and I can get the
information to Tim Dylan Hale
they're open yeah my DM's open so Dylan
Hale if you are listening contact Phil
that remains on Twitter and then he will
get the message to me the challenge for
me is that if I if I tell you to email
me I'll get 8 000 emails by tomorrow and
I won't be able to go through any of
them yeah I get that yeah so everyone
else can follow me too you know yeah
still that remains so Phil will have to
go through the 8 000 emails the 8000 DMS
and then uh and then Dylan we'll send
you 10 grand and don't do like count
dankulan send me pictures of your
testicles so please don't do that why
would you say three years old here's all
the time it all the time so I'll say
this assuming you are working on a book
and we think the book is it's not a
porno yeah it's like a valuable cultural
thing which I assume it is we'll send
you the 10 grand to help you make it as
like and then we will do that as a
statement of we are fully intending to
invest in culture and give back to help
these projects take off and then win the
culture War I want to make sure it's not
vaporware you got to prove it exactly
exactly because everybody in there and
they're you know everybody's going to
try and pull off some kind of like oh
yeah I'm working on something give me
money and they see me at the casino you
know I'm working on your mind but if
it's a book about graphene I think Ian
will just you know automatically yeah we
should start pulling carbon dioxide out
of the aircraft number one seller
tomorrow Ian you're in charge of the
show where we invest in cultural
products like yeah hey okay and then
every proposal is graphene yeah graphene
graphic products graphing guitars what
else is there I'm not wearing my
Graphics
do you have any proposal aren't about
graphene and it's just like I hope the
paper is like uh nine out of ten books
just went out the window on graphene
paper by the way yeah wait wait hold on
this one is about a guy who wants to do
a podcast about graphene so it's not
literally graphic sold
but yeah so uh Dylan if you're listening
you can message Phil that remains on
Twitter
The Fluffy hobo show says I've been
working on getting a Daily Show going so
the idea of a Tim Grant sounds awesome
maybe look at making it an investment
rather than a gift or donation it
depends
um we could totally do Investments and
that would be fantastic as well uh so
that that actually might make sense we
might just do it as like an investment
because then it makes more sense
business-wise depends and I would I
would say this as for whatever we end up
doing it will strongly lean not towards
commentary or like talk shows
because we got a lot of those already
we're literally one what we need is
probably game design that's huge make
video games that
um
have values of meritocracy none of these
weird games where it's like walking
simulator stuff like the metaverse
oh that's creepy but uh comic books
movies short films you know that kind of
stuff I'm sure there's a bunch of others
moving design would be cool yeah
Clothing Design uh Escape culture stuff
skateboards whatever yeah cartoons
Freedom Tunes like stuff you know
whatever if you build like if you're
into architecture and you build stuff
that's pretty cool yeah
yep absolutely
I mean who knows we might be surprised
by the stuff that people present to us
and be like we never even considered
that could be a thing to do and let's do
it you know maybe you want to build a
statue yeah I was just thinking like
maybe there's someone out there that's
like a really nasty sculpture you know
yeah sculptor not sculpting and then we
can like you know one idea we had was we
wanted to crowdsource buying uh a big
plot of land like 200 acres and then
creating like a public space where
people can put things in like you know
like a park of some sort privately on
public space giant Time Capsule no no
just like a space we were like everybody
would would buy a plot of the land a
piece oh I see okay and it'd be a
community-owned thing where anyone could
go and build statues and just make a big
Park you know that way we control
cultural spaces you know
all right what do we got
Goku says Tim there were two guys who
killed the bald eagle with the intent on
eating it they were let go and the FEDS
let them go
that's a felony yeah there you go that's
a felony Nicholas Budden says question
about the money I'm from Australia take
pinealing and I'm currently working on a
classless ttrpg tabletop role-playing
game uh classless sci-fi DND and I was
wondering if I would be able to apply or
would the money only be applicable to
those in the USA I'm not entirely sure
it depends on the legality of it so it
sounds like someone already mentioned
will need judging criteria to make it a
contest and then I imagine we would have
outside advisors choose who the winners
are so it wouldn't be anything related
to us so there's no collusion or
anything like that but uh I don't see
why Australia couldn't you know win or
whatever if you're a member of the show
if you watch the show and you're
supporting us I don't see why you
wouldn't be eligible but I could call my
lawyer tomorrow he might be like no no
no no no only Americans there might be
laws in Australia you know things like
that
we'll see for all I know I call my
accountant my lawyer and they say are
you nuts you can't do that and then I'm
like really
you know there's a way forward there's a
way forward yeah yeah
um I I don't think it's that complicated
because
yeah I think if it's like a a month if
you're a member of the site you can
submit
you know ideas maybe we do as an
investment and then that's completely
straightforward there's always a way for
it well yeah excuse me my hours are
kicking my butt pollination yes it was
pollen but uh look we we figured it out
right in the league we were like how do
we help whistleblowers oh let's go pay
whistleblers the lawyers are like you
can't go play whistleblowers okay so how
does the foundation help whistleblowers
they said once they're established and
come forward with proven information
that they submit to Congress you can
provide them with financial assistance
I think investment makes it the easiest
thing possible that the if you it's like
the same thing right like a one percent
stake for ten thousand dollars or
whatever and then the best part is you
get some ridiculous evaluation based on
that investment or they submit their
final product to you and they say this
is what we want to do and then you're
like oh you're a winner here go fund
you're already completed product I think
if we get something in exchange we don't
got to worry about rules or anything
like that well that's different yeah
yeah if we say like we'll take five
percent or well that's what the Shark
Tank guys do right right they take a
piece of the action then it's just
submit it's your ideas and maybe we'll
invest well if it's a non-profit then I
think the only other thing you got to do
if you're doing shark tank for
nonprofits and what do you do with the
percentage you have well now we're
timcast is a for-profit no Tim so I'm
saying if we just did it as if the
company just invested in it then yeah
you can do that that's the easiest way
to do it probably and that makes the
most business sense we're not just
throwing money out you know at people
and saying it is a lot of liability for
the company if it takes on another more
Investments sort of uh owning a piece of
a company
yeah but we're gonna talk to the lawyer
about it for sure but you know
maybe we'll have to make a company that
does Holdings specifically for this some
kind of culture War you know
I bet between the two of us you probably
more than me know enough rich people to
create a culture War investment fund I'm
in let's do it yeah I'm not kidding okay
I'll call five donors tomorrow yeah
let's do it
and then we'll we'll try and figure out
how to invest more into people who are
building culture and it doesn't take a
lot you give like like these guys are
saying on your super chats 5 10 grand
that's a lot of money to get someone
going on just a little project and you
know some of the bigger projects would
be like 20 25 Grand but really what it
comes down to is
uh Oscar Gonzalez real quick asks is it
only eligible to the U.S I would I think
the answer is no but we'll see I I talk
to lawyers but the the simple thing is
we may get a hundred submissions we may
eventually fund 100 projects
only one of them works that's the
reality it's a scattered shot someone
writes a song and then it just takes off
and we're like we did not think that was
gonna be the one I mean actually Phil
has it happened to you guys like you
think one song is going to be the hit
and then it turns out the other song was
the hit so there's this song that people
are very familiar with called six from a
record called the fall of ideals and
that was the first song that we ever put
on a video game they called me up I'm
like 30 years old they're like yo we're
gonna put your song in a video game I'm
like that is the coolest thing that I
have heard in my life and I figured it
was going to be the single the song
called this calling and they're like
we're gonna do six I'm like you know
that song starts with double bass a
blast beat and me screaming my head off
and they're like yes I'm like you're
crazy but that's awesome I just want it
on a video game and then the song turned
into became huge it's huge huge I've
heard a bunch of stories from people who
are like this was the song we thought
was going to be the one yeah and then
for some reason it was this one we
thought was like a b side actually I
think a good example of that is uh
metric the song Black Sheep I guess the
story I could be is wrong but it was in
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World and they were
asked by uh the people making the movie
if they had a song they could use and
they said well here's one we weren't
going to put on the album it didn't fit
and now it's their biggest song
so it's like you never know anyway
that's the point though we'll take a
bunch of uh Investments and the reality
is maybe your ID doesn't take off that's
the unfortunate reality but eventually
someone's gonna hit it and then we're
gonna start winning that culture War so
Sergeant Beck wants to call it gofund
yourself
Tim
fund me uh no go go fund yourself is
good that's great go fund yourself all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com for my birthday would you
not it's coming up on Thursday but we're
gonna have a members only show with cash
we will have that on the front page of
the website in about 10 or so minutes
we're going to wrap this show up
everyone's gonna go to the bathroom grab
something to drink we'll be setting up
the live show for members only and we
hope to see you there you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast cash you want to
shout anything out uh I appreciate you
guys having me go to government
gangsters.com get my pre-order to check
out the truth Donald Trump launched the
book for pre-sale he calls it the blue
map the blueprint for winning back the
White House and returning the agencies
and departments to serve the gov to
serve the American people working people
where people find you on social media
one place I'm on Truth social at cash at
k-a-s-h check us out check out the
policy videos we're putting out and all
the fun we're having at just throwing
paint up against everything I also want
to point people at thecashfoundation.com
thank you yeah that's the best thing I
do honestly literally to get people
together to provide financial assistance
to whistleblowers to to Jan sticks
families in need to if you're being sued
and you need a legal defense we'll pay
for it active duty service members it
all goes back into the 51c3 the cash
foundation and we got some cool merch
check it out thank you guys
I am Phil Labonte lead singer of All
That Remains I'm Phil it remains on
Twitter I'm Philip remains official on
Instagram and listen chat even if I
don't wear the wet with the white hat
anymore I still already purchased it all
right wait Phil we got to get you on
Truth social oh I have I'm Phil that
remains on Truth social as well oh there
you go I think I need to get a truth
Social account I'm going to talk to you
that maybe I have one I don't know uh
what's up everybody Ian crosson here
remember when you're building culture it
can be a little confusing like how do I
do that but when when a culture grows
it's because there are things in it that
are duplicating so you want to make the
thing focus on the thing focus on the
song or the the chair or that the house
whatever you're building and the culture
is the result of the growth of that
so uh keep building stuff and I'll see
you later
yeah that was cool
cool show uh yeah I uh hope you guys uh
follow me on Twitter I never thought I'd
have 5 000 people following me on
Twitter it's kind of crazy right on
surge Hyde yeah so tired we'll do that
yeah all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com in about 10
minutes for the live uncensored members
only portion of the show thanks for
hanging out